so NBC runs this segment where they
basically say it's Madison he's like if
the Neo-Nazi faction of the GOP expands
in November we may look back on this a
pivotal moment when a petulant a not so
bright billionaire bought one of the
most influential messaging machines and
handed it to the far right
it's a ridiculous thing to say but of
course NBC is a ridiculous Network and
Elon Musk responds by basically going
off and then questioning why it is that
we didn't get The Client List for
Maxwell and Epstein and I'm just like
well this dude's losing it and then Elon
goes are they why are they writing my
Suicide story already and I'm like yo
this dude is going off
it's gonna be fun we got to go through
this and talk about it we got a bunch of
other stories too though got a bunch of
like weird cultural stories because one
of the big things that's been in the
news with Elon Musk talking about the
left going too far left is now you've
got these leftists who are like but we
nominated Joe Biden and he's a moderate
he's a Centrist and it's just like dude
Joe Biden says affirm your kids like
that's a huge departure from where
Barack Obama was in 2008 when he was
opposing gay marriage so we got to talk
about that
diesel prices are the highest they've
ever been so expect your paycheck to not
go that far and for prices to hurt a
whole lot and uh we got we got a whole
bunch of stuff hopefully we'll get to
all of it we have this historically New
York Times where they're trying to
defend a book that was in public schools
depicting uh let's just call it adult
activities for children and when the
right got mad and they were like hey we
kind of don't want these images in our
libraries for kids just find the New
York Times runs a story saying it's just
a bunch of like extremists far right you
know homophobes or whatever and I'm like
dude if if not wanting kids to be
exposed to this stuff is far right then
I don't know what that means for this
country because these leftists who are
pushing this stuff are not in the
majority but they they they they they
make you think they are and then the
people in the media just play this up so
we're gonna get into all that stuff
joining us to talk about all this is
Danny polish Chuck hello who are you
good sir I am a comedian I host the
podcast with Ryan long called The Boys
cast and I host a Colin show called Low
value mail every m-a-i-l every Tuesday
night at nine o'clock
and you some people might know me as the
deranged uh employee of Twitter I'm sure
there's some person right now watching
this goes hey isn't that that crazy guy
who works at Twitter so and yeah as a
thing you posted yeah well I had
literally 200 000 people who thought I
actually worked for Twitter wow it was
almost obviously it's hurtful I that's
what I thought I thought that was very
obvious that this is a green screen I
said my name was Tony Fernandez
because I always picked uh former
Toronto Blue Jays for every sketch I do
is the name and so and then people were
like they were it says Tony Fernandez
and they're like Danny jokes I can't go
why don't you quit if you don't want to
work at Twitter I'm like I said my name
was Tony Fernandez oh well I guess we'll
just have to talk about that so uh we
also have Seamus Sheamus yeah I can
relate there was a while ago on the show
where Tim said what do you how do you
define like racist or something and I
said Trump supporter which if anyone
knows obviously a joke and there are
people in the chat like I can't I
thought I can't believe Sheamus hates
Trump but
um yeah I'm Sheamus Cagle and I make
cartoons at a channel called Freedom
Tunes so you all should go check them
out and by the way low value Mel that is
a brilliant name shout out to female
dating strategy for that one what's up
everybody Ian crossing here I got a uh
Tim got got me this actually this is
pizza labradorite I wanted to show you
so hard to see oh never mind whenever I
see rocks I just think of Ian look at
this it's got this labradorescence Lydia
just pulled up just looked it up it's an
effect where you can see kind of almost
see through the labradorite so cool yeah
man this is actually an expensive sphere
other than that oh I got nothing else
a new a new rock to show us like show
and tell with you I'm Gonna Roll
100-sided die let's find out let's see
what we got oh we got 70. up against the
labrador ride oh nice seven zero that is
a strong start earlier tonight we're
learning about labradorescence
Apparently that is a thing that I did
not know about I also love labradorite
it is beautiful you guys check it out it
doesn't look anything like it does here
on the show looks way better in real
life well all right before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member because
as a member you will be supporting our
journalists where we just hired a
journalist recently we're gonna be
hiring a couple more calmness we're
taking more columns more opinion pieces
we are expanding and you'll get access
to exclusive segments from this show the
timcast irol members only podcast Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM and we're also
going to do just a whole bunch of other
stuff I can't say too much because if we
give away our plans for our culture
jamming strategies then uh you ruin them
but if you liked what we did with the
billboard in Times Square you're going
to love what we've got planned for this
summer because because of your support
as members allowing us to do this stuff
we've got we've got some we've got some
uh news cycle setting plans and when I
say we just I can't reveal who but uh
talking to some masterful trolls about
what can we do to send a message that's
good marketing that also challenges The
Establishment and asserts our presence
and will just trigger uh trigger these
uh blue checkies so we got some plans
it's going to be fun so thank you all so
much for making this possible to dream
come true and I'm going to really enjoy
what we have coming up the next few
months so don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and let's
get into this first story with a big
shout out to Elon Musk we have this clip
Tom Elliott posted it's NBC's Maddie
Hassan saying if the Neo-Nazi faction of
the GOP expands in November we may look
back on this as a pivotal moment when a
petulant and not so bright billionaire
casually bought one of the most
influential messaging machines and just
handed it to the far right the first
thing I have to do is point out anybody
who calls a billionaire not so bright
insane I know it's just not so bright
come on the question is why aren't you a
billionaire it's easy yeah yeah idiots
can do it go ahead and try it
Rockets into space and then Landing them
on like islands that are a little larger
than the rocket he's also self-made I
for the most part he sold PayPal for to
make his first big chunk of money he
risked everything to make Tesla but he
had white skin while doing it yes his
family's rich oh yeah no I'm sure look
but hold on I I know a lot of kids whose
families were rich and instead they went
to art school and didn't get a job
if you can be in an idiot and become a
billionaire just because your parents
were Rich it's so easy why aren't these
people able to do it when they call
Trump an idiot I'm like I mean Brash
maybe but the dude turned a million
dollars into a billion dollars I mean
you gotta that's you gotta be smart also
the idea that you just have a million
dollars and become a millionaire like
that or it's not the case yeah but the
funny thing is we're talking about Elon
Musk and you mentioned with the Rockets
he's like the first guy to land a rocket
upright back on a platform and it's like
this tremendous feat he lowered the cost
of rocketry like tenfold or 100 fold and
he's making space travel infinitely
cheaper
he's got starlink low latency satellites
and they're like what an idiot yeah
just pulls it wrong he's an idiot also
if if having Rich parents sets you up
for success and it's just a guarantee
you walk into it explain Hunter Biden
yeah oh man but let's be real I mean
Define he's making money too I mean I
mean I I spent 650 000 on a painting of
his so I don't know oh my yeah look I
mean craftsmanship is craftsmanship and
you have to reward good work well let's
let's talk about what uh what Elon says
so Elon Musk responds with NBC basically
saying Republicans are Nazis oh he then
says same organization that covered up
Hunter button laptop story had Harvey
Weinstein's story early and killed it
and built Matt Lauer his rape off his
lovely people that's a low blow you on
in the lake office when I saw that I was
like I am retweeting this it's amazing
yo Elon is Unleashed you know what this
is what I've been I've been wanting to
see right I I've always asked myself
this when I was when I was younger I'm
like there's so much going on in the
world that people complain about where
are these billionaires to just do
anything I mean seriously anything like
what did Oprah do she people got mad at
Oprah because she she had this big event
on Michigan Avenue in Chicago where
there's like a helicopter shot of all
these people in an audience watching a
musical performance but then all of a
sudden all the people start doing a
choreographed dance and you realize
they're all paid actors and people got
mad because they were like if you were
gonna do a show do a show but this is
all one big setup I remember seeing it
and thinking like that's what they do
with their money they just get a bunch
of dancers to dance in the street where
the Billboards saying like screw this
guy and F this or like I'm mad about
that like very rarely so now you get
Elon Musk
Matt Lauer's rape office yo but check
this out
pope of muskanity says it says it all
that we heard more about Will Smith
slapping Chris Rock than we heard about
Guillain Maxwell's trial it is also
interesting that the account tracking
the Maxwell trials got Maxwell trial got
banned when it gained attraction lovely
people indeed and then Elon Musk says
where is their Client List shouldn't at
least one of them go down and then hey
why are they already writing my Suicide
story
uh dude I uh that last one strikes a
little bit too uh real because there's
no way they're gonna like the powerful
Elites massive corporations politicians
what are they gonna do sit back and let
a rogue billionaire just go off I think
he answered your question why we don't
see more billionaires calling people out
because you basically paint a bullseye
on your forehead if you do that the
world is a dark dangerous place and if
you cross the wrong people man that's it
I was gonna say that I mean if you were
a billionaire who was just okay with it
all ending this would be the coolest
possible
after Grimes left him he was just like I
don't care anymore he's not just going
off oh Elon Elon it gets better all
right hang in there buddy hang in there
man you guys ever see bullworth
no it's that movie where the politician
hires an assassin right yeah you know
what it is he hires a guy to kill
himself right so then he's just like
drinking and doesn't care anymore starts
telling the truth and everyone loves it
and then he doesn't want to die and he's
like freaking out that movie was pretty
good I liked it I I'm starting to think
that this is the reason that Elon Musk
bought Twitter so that he could just um
ish post all day long this is amazing
he's going crazy couldn't he do that
before kind of it's weird that they make
him out they say he's like a republican
like he doesn't seem overly political to
be honest he's outright called himself a
socialist yeah like he doesn't come off
his posts are a lot of like you know
jokes and but he doesn't seem super
political before the show I was thinking
dude creates rocket ships to space and
Mars people on Earth complaining about
what what his politics are like it's so
insane that that's the focus when you
can focus on the stuff he's building
look at look at that Nina jankowicks
lady the disinformation board she pushes
over disinformation and has so she's
supposedly like working she's working
for the Democrats
when you look at Elon Musk I think it's
never been clearer that left and right
don't mean anything about politics it
means everything about whether you are
on your knees for the establishment or
challenging The Establishment yeah also
Ian you made an interesting point I
would even take it a step further
because it's not even like he has this
political agenda he's trying to force
onto people like he he's in a lot of
ways he's virtually apolitically saying
let's just make neutral spaces that's
not really a partisan stance and he's
not greedy either he gave his Tesla
patents away the free the yeah all your
patents are belong to us move that he
did I got to push back on Sheamus
Sheamus he is handing over one of the
most influential messaging platforms to
neo-nazis well here's what I think
elon's gonna do if they don't let him
buy Twitter something falls through he's
going to build a rocket ship that
projects it's going to be like a space
platform that projects whatever he
writes into the sky like have you seen
the drones the fireworks drone they're
replacing fireworks with with drone cool
kind of like uh that you can write stuff
on you let's do that over every city
dude they're getting really crazy
three-dimensional like they look like
Holograms is your drone light show way
cooler than fireworks yeah yeah they're
way cooler than fireworks and also you
don't like blow your hand off this is
like two years old
yeah I know well they had the one at
Bitcoin Miami they did uh but in China
they're like oh yeah because they can
move really far really fast and draw
lines in the sky has anyone thought
about the horror of just like someone
like Elon getting a thousand drones and
then being able to command them with the
gloves I'm like walking through New York
and just like protoss man that's how the
protoss move their battle Cruisers
around are there over someone's head
like a rain cloud no no he's like he's
he's wearing a trench coat and he's
standing on several drones as he's
floating for the city you know then when
anyone challenges him he just points and
a drone flies and slams into him now
we're talking Bezos level like Bezos has
the proprietor's ideas yeah Elon at
least is freeing the software code of
his stuff so if I was Bezos I would
legit be doing that I would make one of
those hobgoblin gliders from Spider-Man
and then I would just have drones and
I'd be like is he gonna set up his base
in the Amazon would you if you were Jeff
Bezos
Legion of Doom well I know he called his
company Amazon so I'm wondering if
there's something more I love you Jeff
I'm just joking what is it that uh I
can't remember exactly how we put what
is it that Jeremy boring said he's like
he's the most interesting guy in a
boring way like he's the most boring
interesting guy about Bezos yeah what
did he say like he makes a rocket ship
and it's not cool
it's not like cool that is funny though
Jeff he said what did he yeah he he put
it really funny it's boring interesting
person butchered it we ruined your jokes
so check this out so people responded
well when Elon Musk said where's their
Client List someone said let's start
with you and they show this photo where
Guillain Maxwell is behind Elon and he
says that's a vendy fair party and she
photobombed me in the background but you
know that already don't you who and then
someone respond to this guy pernay Elon
doesn't know gilan Maxwell at all she
photobombed him once at a Vanity Fair
party in 2014. real question is why
Vanity Fair invited her in the first
place and he said that is exactly the
question indeed dude I think I'm you
gotta look if Elon Musk is going to come
out and say Where's The Client List I'm
like Elon by the way do what you want to
do because it's one of the most
important questions yeah that's not not
going to be answered there's no C any
serious journalist at the Washington
Post at the New York Times I'll say this
right out to all of you I know that
there are people at the New York Times
have been working there for two decades
and you are upset about what's happening
at your newspaper I know that there are
people at the Washington Post who have
been there for decades who are upset
about what is happening to your
newspaper why don't you start demanding
answers as to The Client List for
Maxwell and Epstein why why isn't there
any interest from the gray lady the
paper of record and all of these big
Publications to demand if this woman is
being convicted on this she sold
something to somebody it's Elon Musk
yeah and he's the bad guy they're saying
he's the bad guy I think those people
have families
um yeah when I look at Maria farmer who
is one of the former victims of the the
I don't call it child trafficking
racketeering thing they're doing and she
drew a painting called the set heels
s-e-t-i-l-e-s her name is Maria farmer
you search those three words together
you'll get this painting and it looks
like she just painted all the guys all
the people that were there as part of it
she doesn't have names but I mean I
can't imagine anyone digging too deep
into it but this is the deepest I've
seen and it's like it's a really
disturbing image uh it's got giland in
the Middle with a bubble around her like
she's she's Invincible it's got Jeffrey
Epstein's off up in the corner like he's
some space get that he was the Fall Guy
for the whole thing he wasn't like and
then of course you got I don't even like
saying these names out loud man but you
got Les Wexner right in the middle there
under gee Lane Maxwell the Victoria's
Secret guy and uh I think he was a big
part of it but there's just no I don't
have the evidence it's just this image I
want to pull up this story here we have
about Bill Maher from the daily wire
Bill Maher rips old Twitter mocks
Trudeau and gives a shout out to the
Babylon bee and this I was watching this
clip from Bill Maher when he was talking
about Elon Musk and the purchasing and
everything and it made me realize what's
happening with the establishment what's
happening with um you know Elon
the older the boomer generation they
consume their news through cable
television
this is why there are so many people who
are like Tucker Carlson's far right
because they these are older people who
are only getting their news from CNN and
MSNBC and then Fox News is like the
other side so there's like three
channels but most of us and the people
our age are on Twitter or on Facebook or
on YouTube so we're getting a big
spattering of all this different news
but it's coming really quickly
I saw this and Bill Maher his confusion
like a dottering old man and I was just
like wow you know I think it's fair to
say one day we will all be old and
confused but don't he doesn't need to be
so watching this here's what happens
Bill Maher says did you hear about this
Babylon bee it's Christian satire
everybody laughs and then as guest goes
oh yeah because we need that and Bill
goes well maybe some people do I'm not
everybody some people do need it and
then I'm watching that and I'm like Bill
did you not Google search this story
when it happened are you just now
finding out after Elon already bought
Twitter what the Babylon B is
and I wondered why it is well CNN won't
report on what the Babylon B is no so
sir someone like Bill Maher who's a 60
year old Boomer who gets his news from
The New York Times physical paper
Edition and from cable television he
just now found out about the Babylon bee
it was March 20th Elon was like should
we have free speech and stuff like that
that he was he was asking these
questions that the Babylon B was in the
news and we we were all watching in real
time this progress of Elon Musk and Bill
Maher one of the most prominent shows
he's confused and just now finding out
he's in a show called real time yeah
mine's out like a month later
I'm not trying to rag on him I think
it's just you got to point out that he's
in a different world who's his boss well
look he's in a different world and now
think about what that means for every
other news story think about what that
means for Hunter Biden's laptop think
about that means for Epstein all of
these Boomers they're they vote and they
and they're like they mostly vote
they're like they vote when more than
young people and they don't know
half of what we know they don't know a
tenth of what we know because we all saw
the Epstein Story in real time and Bill
Maher probably never saw it I mean I'm
I'm being hyperbolic but vilmar probably
sees it a month later and he's like
what's going on with this and it's like
Bill that was that was a month ago yeah
it seems like it's like a safety
mechanism to wait to let the news out a
month later like the hunter Biden laptop
thing they wanted to just hold it for a
month granted it was right before the
election yeah
once it's a month late it just doesn't
have the fire it doesn't have the heat
like the iron's no longer hot Bill Maher
has called out the woke he's criticized
to this stuff the fact that he's done
that I think shows he's willing to but
he's like an old man who's looking at
his phone being like I can't press the
button and it's like he's just not on
these platforms he works for Warner
Brothers yeah yeah he even said I've
heard him say it is like you know
there's only so much I can really get
away with I have corporate you know my
incorporation was my check sure sure but
if he's talking about the Babylon Bean
now he could have talked about the
Babylon be a month ago when the story
broke was he talking about the Rachel
Levine thing like in them he's talking
he's talking about how Babylon B made a
Sater video about Twitter employees be
freaking out and it's actually really
funny the uh the Twitter health expert
yeah yeah he's like he's got a Rorschach
test like what do you see she's like
Nazis Nazis Hitler Nazis no one looks
like lips I hope people don't think that
guy works for Twitter too but it's it's
really funny because uh the bit was
really good she's he's like tell me do
you see Elon here now and she's like she
looks at a tennis ball it's got elon's
face she looks at like an employee
pamphlet on the wall and it's got It's
Elon on it it was actually really funny
but Bill Maher was mentioning that
Twitter flagged it as sensitive content
and he was like it's a satirical video
mocking you for being too sensitive and
you flagged it as sensitive material
I'm just look that's fine he's speaking
up he's calling it out but why a month
late the point is I think Bill's a good
dude I think you know to a certain
extent he's trying but if the boomer
generation isn't paying attention
because we had Richie McGinnis and his
mom on and Richie's mom also Boomer
didn't know about what was going on with
today's Politics the boomer generation
is like I think they're just totally
different realities Marvel's for the
most part he's incentivized to not dig
too deep like his original show uh what
was it politically Politically Incorrect
got canceled he went hard on 911 and
like if he did that today if he came out
and was like let's talk about the Deep
state in the military industrial complex
they'd be like yeah Warner Brothers
would be like this is a little too racy
although I think real time really is
just that show renamed but just a little
that's a little you remember when uh
Dennis Prager was on vilmar yeah I think
it was like 2017 and he was like the
left is lying they're lying and he's
like a man cannot menstruate they're
lying and then everyone laughs yeah
everybody like
R goes wait wait wait what are you
talking about and uh Prager mentions
that University bathrooms they were
putting tampons in the men's room and
bill says that's for men to bring to
their girlfriends
that one really frustrated me because
the story was actually at that point
like seven years old about bathrooms
with men's rooms with tampons but this
is this is exactly what what I think we
see
I'm not trying to say that every single
boom or anything like that I'm saying on
average if you look at the average age
of a cable TV news viewer it's 62 to 69
or whatever
they're consuming all their news from
the likes of Don Lemon no that's not
gonna work out well for us yeah also
with Mars with Bill Maher's response
that they're just putting them in there
so guys can get tampons for their
girlfriends or their girlfriend could
just go to the girl's bathroom right
next to it that makes no sense as an
explanation that's like the most
ridiculous I don't want to believe what
I'm being told to answer I've ever heard
yeah that's a crazy explanation I think
I think Dennis could have been more
prepared but sometimes you're in these
moments and you make a point and you're
not prepared to back it up so when they
were like where what are you talking
about I said just look it up it's like I
could tell you oh is it September 2016
The Daily Beast wrote up that we have to
do it look that up specifically uh side
note the Daily Beast is now listed as
fake I love it
I get this Dynamic with comedians
sometimes where they'll be like they'll
say something stupid or irrelevant and
then if you start to make fun I'm gonna
come on it was a jokey [ __ ] but then if
you say something stupid or irrelevant
they're like you stupid idiot yeah I I
know exactly what you mean but they go
like I was just I was just a goof you
know you know what is dangerous for
um post-liberal whatever whatever this
Freedom faction is I don't know they say
left and right and I'm like I don't even
know that that doesn't it doesn't
explain anything to anybody but uh the
side that believes in Freedom what's
dangerous is that we see the CNN news
stories about the Insurrection and MSNBC
and Rachel Maddow and we all laugh like
that's so dumb no one cares and then you
look at their ratings and you're like
CNN and MSNBC get like 400 million
combined views on YouTube every month
and we get I think 60. so I mean we're
doing well but it's mostly young people
these older people are going to vote and
they're going to vote based on some
weird Insurrection narrative other than
voting the people that watch the show
for the most part are listening to what
we're saying the words very word by word
it's all like registering and they're
remembering when you have these other
shows that get propped up it's like in
one ear and out the other not
necessarily every time but it seems to
be and this is also for a lot of I think
your listeners are this is just a piece
to an overall puzzle they take this
piece of information they take pieces of
information from other places whereas
someone on CNN they're just like I watch
CNN they give me my opinions and those
are my opinions and you know maybe I
watch MSNBC but like for the most part
they're not kind of like going and
sourcing it from
well this is yeah this is one of the
things that Richie's mom was bringing up
she was saying that there used to only
be like three networks and you trusted
them and they said things in a very kind
of reassuring way and you felt confident
in what they were telling you and I
think a lot of that has carried over for
Boomers which has turned into a huge
problem because they can just now tell
them whatever they want to and they'll
just believe it like it's a little
unsettling I was talking to my mom about
some awesome stuff about this like just
cool like let's talk about conspiracy
she was like Ian man if I was 20 I'd be
I'd be okay I'd be into it but I just
it's just I'm I'm done I'm ready to I
finally got my mom to go on Twitter
actually I convinced her she was how
would you do that to her well because I
kept saying because she would she's like
you know the classic do you get the
emails from like you ever get my mom
just sends me emails of these articles
you know this is interesting and I was
like yeah I read this on Twitter like a
week and a half ago yeah this is you
know but that's new to her because
that's like the the delay on the cycle
that's what Bill Maher's doing kind of
yeah it kind of is and I go you need to
go on Twitter to just and you can you
know cut out this delay and get the news
far superior way to get the news
absolutely let me give a shout out to
Michael malice here he's got a sweet he
says the ministry of Truth demonstrates
the growing inability of the cathedral
to persuade and an increasing need to
just explicitly tell people what to
believe people have gone from arguing to
either ignoring or presuming not
incorrectly that it's all disingenuous
propaganda at best
we're at the point now where I think on
both sides people are just absolutely
unwilling to hear what the other point
is being made at all and my view of what
is colloquially colloquially referred to
as the right which is this large faction
of mostly like some kind of libertarian
is that they want proof they want
sources back up your Source back up your
claim not all of them there's there's a
a group of trump supporters who believe
absolutely insane things and you can see
them out there at the rallies with
Trump's going to be president on this
day or whatever and never happens but
next time it will but sure yeah but I
think that's the the exception not the
rule on the left it's the inverse the
average person on the left believes
every single fake story I'm really
interested we've got some lefties coming
on the show soon that we're booking and
I think it's going to be really
interesting for me to be like hey
Trayvon Martin story Zimmerman did you
believe that you did okay well NBC
edited the audio to make Zimmerman seem
racist and he's hispanic how about uh
Covington kids did you believe that well
we learned that was fake News justice
Millet all these people came out and
supported them that was fake news Russia
gate fake news Ukraine gate fake news
how many uh ghost of Kiev isn't that
black fake news are they doing that
again
it was fake admitted it was fake so my
point is now that the ministry of Truth
is Out and About they're like oh we
gotta play it close here this is the
only thing I can surmise when when the
Washington Post as or the media matter
smears the whole show or something like
you know Sheamus says my opinion as
right wing or far right or grifting I'm
like I guess the only thing that defines
what it is to be left or right is do you
fall for bullish or do you wait for
evidence yeah Thomas Massey pointed out
that Congress basically split between
the the like the logical people and the
emotional people and a lot of them are
leading with emotion but either extreme
is dangerous like too much emotion you
don't care about the facts it's just you
get your and then too much logic you
don't care about how people feel you
might end up you know experimenting on
human bodies to get your so you gotta
that's what that's what so right we've
seen societies that are only driven by
Logic and they put people's arms into
Sub-Zero temperatures to watch them
freeze while still attached to their
bodies you know and I will I want to
give a shout out though to all of the
media Outlets that were trying to smear
me for defending Kyle Rittenhouse prove
my point I was right yeah it wasn't
about being conservative or liberal it
was like Hey I watched a video and
here's what really happened Kyle was
defending him self then they all come
out and they scream the far right
because they're lying non-stop then it
turns out to be correct so I'm really
fascinated this is what the left and the
right is name a left-wing political
position irrelevant I can sit here all
day and we can talk about Taxation and
and you know social policy or whatever
but the real question is which stories
did you fall for if you don't fall for
the lies you're right wing yeah well in
you're correct that their positions are
Irrelevant in many ways and even they
will acknowledge this so on the one hand
whenever anyone points up there's a
problem with the far left their response
is oh why because we want free health
care like what is the far left even mean
and then someone like Tim comes out and
says hey I'm actually in favor of free
healthcare as well but they still call
you fall far right because you don't
fall for the same stories they do that's
the weirdest thing what is what is right
and left yeah what do you think of so
there's this disinformation governance
board I don't know if you guys talked
about this but what happens when
the next president is Trump or DeSantis
and he goes okay we have this
disinformation governance board
she's out my guy's in
but well that's insane no no no no no I
I think if it's Trump or DeSantis they
might just dissolve it instantly well
they might but I'm saying I'm just
saying hypothetically yeah if it was
Mitt Romney somehow gets elected yeah
then he's gonna be like it's time to put
on a new guy who's gonna talk about
what's the real truth if it's
descendants or Trump Trump's going to be
like I'm getting rid of it it's wrong
but imagine the hysterics if he goes
yeah you guys great idea everyone last
Administration I love this idea here's
my guy but yeah that that was true back
when the establishment were playing a
game of hot potato when it was like John
McCain versus Obama it was just chill
establishment didn't matter who came
into Power you know George W bush comes
in with all these wars and Barack
Obama's like we're gonna change it Dan
gets in it's like I'm gonna kill kids
instead then Barack Obama signs the
indefinite detention Provisions then
Barack Obama increases the Drone attacks
and you know that if a republican like
Mitt Romney were to win it wouldn't
matter but then Trump won and he broke
these people yeah so we were sort of
talking about that the other day and
I don't think that's an effective thing
to say to left Wingers unfortunately
because they know that while
right-wingers could use that power to be
authoritarian and suppress them that
they actually need that power in order
to survive because in order for like
left-wing Orthodoxy to flourish you
basically have to scare people into
pretending to believe something else
because No One's Gonna like voluntarily
agree to the idea that children should
change their genders not the number that
people are giving a cent to it now well
this is this is the crazy thing that
two things occur when I made I made a
point on Twitter I said it's crazy that
if you believe children shouldn't be
getting sex change surgery you're
considered right wing two things
happened one I got called a transphobe
and two people were like that's not
happening you're lying the left isn't
doing that and the response to every
single person who says that is someone
showing a news story talking about
medical intervention chemical or or
Surgical and it's literally happening so
either you're a lying grifter who's
pushing right-wing talking points to
your right wing or you're a transphobes
to your right wing and I'm like dude
okay whatever I guess right the the
um the quintessential left-wing position
that's not happening but it's good that
it's happening you're bad for opposing
it I don't think it's transphobic to to
care about to protect children from you
know gender surgery sexual surgeries at
that point you know being transphobic is
like meeting someone that's an adult
person that's trans and being like I
don't want to be anywhere near that
person or I'm going to talk crap about
them we do have a bunch of stories
specifically addressing that in schools
but I do want to focus on this real
quick while we're talking about like me
media manipulation and lies we have this
from the New York Post new CNN boss
Chris Licht to focus on Truth after slew
of scandals Chris it is Honorable that
you would try to purge CNN of its trash
but you will never you will never save
that brand I'm sorry
CNN's new boss kicked off his first day
on the job by telling employees he wants
to focus the Network's reporting on news
and Truth amid criticism over the
Scandal scarred Network's heavy emphasis
on opinion based shows Chris Licht to
officially replace CNN's disgrace to
boss Zucker on Monday following stints
as executive producer at The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert and CBS This
Morning circulated a memo to his
employees saying too many people have
lost trust in the news media I think we
can be a beacon in regaining that trust
by being an organization that
exemplifies the best characteristics of
Journalism fearlessly speaking truth to
power challenging the status quo
questioning group think and educating
viewers and readers with straightforward
facts and insightful commentary while
always being respectful of differing
viewpoints first and foremost we should
and we will be advocates for the truth
you know why sang that
because the dude who now owns the
majority shareholder and Warner
Discovery said he wanted to or something
happened where it came out it was
reported he wanted to purge all of the
opinion Lefty garbage from CNN so this
guy's like I don't want to lose my job I
Believe In Truth as if I'm ever going to
go to CNN for truth so I can't stand the
subjectivity of truth truth or object a
truth is not an objective State people
perceive reality as objective but the
way you perceive it is your truth so
people are going to see reality in
different ways for one person to attempt
to arbitrate that as Insanity here come
the ones give me the ones give me all
the ones give me 20 of them also what
would CNN be like what what does he
Envision CNN to be with you know it's
like it's going to be this good thing
you're going to purge all that like in
this scenario where it's all purging all
these like you know the far like what is
this going to become just it's late
night with yeah Stephen Colbert yeah I
don't know part two apparently exactly
how could this guy have worked on
Colbert think he's gonna everyone's
gonna trust him he probably did the
vaccine
who was it who did the fouchy thing
where they were dancing and then they
had the thing that's they spread it open
and they were spinning with it and it
was like a big picture James Corden
[Laughter]
um
wow that song we should oh it's just
like
you know Sheamus
it's it's the Jeff Bezos you know it's
like
these shows like Colbert they exemplify
that joke Jeremy boring made about Bezos
they're they're wealthy and Powerful but
just so not cool and it's just absolute
cringe you know seriously when when
Colbert for those who didn't see it he
did this thing where he had like was it
like women and men dress up like
syringes yeah
I can't believe he went there
I have a couple questions though did
they do any market research and if they
did who were they targeting
are there like
there's no one my I can't imagine
anybody in the key demo is watching that
going like I enjoy Colbert whoever
watches it like the people who like
Colbert probably were like this is great
I've always thought he was trash like on
the on The Daily Show when he got to
start uh as a correspondent he was just
a liar and a fake he was doing comedy
but he was alive he was doing a
character then he got his new show where
he's playing the Republican fake guy and
he tells people he would literally he
was like satire show but he would say
things that he didn't believe as they
were real and like just screw people's
minds bull crap artist and then he's on
this show like we're supposed to all of
a sudden believe anything out of this
guy he's a trash liar for a job I mean
maybe he's a nice funny guy but I've
never seen him like dig under the
surface he was great on Strangers With
Candy if you ever saw that oh gosh I
couldn't bring myself to watch actually
it did look like he was pretty good in
that movie like as an actor at the show
as a show but yeah he's a talented actor
yeah as you can see he's playing around
his new show is it's as bad as it gets I
don't know I don't try I've never
trusted him I made a video on 06 about
this about Colbert's Artistry is his
crap Artistry I never liked that guy and
when Jack the Subic came on here and
said that Jon Stewart Stephen Colbert
were the spearheads of the
politicization of of comedy and
basically I think it makes so much sense
like
no oh God no no no okay well I was just
going to say that I remember that years
ago we talked about this on the show a
little while ago actually on this
episode about the whole clown nose on
clown knows off thing that a lot of
these late night hosts and particularly
Jon Stewart would do I remember he got
into a debate with Tucker Carlson and he
was grilling Tucker and Tucker starts
pointing out factual inaccuracies with
Jon Stewart's showing his reporting and
he goes because it's a comedy show it's
like oh was that the bit was that the
bit that you were getting facts wrong on
purpose no you wanted your audience to
think that that was true the jokes were
in other parts of the program like
that's so obnoxious Stuart is one of
those guys that he'll say something and
then if you get dig into him he's like
hey I'm a comedian layoff idiot but then
if you said he's like no you know try
and throw his like weight of being
popular at you it's really gross and
it's like it's fine to do jokes and
politics right but if you're saying
something that you intend for people to
believe as true and it turns out to be
false you don't get to fall back I'm
like oh come on man I make jokes don't
take anything I say serious you know
yeah no I don't like it well this is the
embodiment of that obnoxious kid when
you were younger being like you know I
I'm just playing you know I'm just
playing I'm just joking but if he can
get away with it he will so this is
Classic this I love you Danny but
comedians sometimes do this where they
like to pull up the ladder after them I
don't know if you've noticed this but oh
that's better perfect
[Laughter]
ladder after them and I really feel like
this is just like um literally so many
of my favorite comedians all of them
it's all like David Cross used to be
literally my favorite comedian and now
and he did all the stuff where he's
almost like he's now apologizing for
everything he did and he's like
everything I did that was so funny eight
years ago is you know all cancelable
stuff oh like the guy that took all the
psychedelics and he's like hey don't do
psychedelics yeah yeah I I had a great
time like the 90s were a great decade
but you were just water for you you know
I gotta I I've been I'm wondering though
like if this can last so I pulled up
Colbert's ratings he had a total average
viewer of 2.95 million and this was
reported as of June 9th of 2021 so last
year he was getting 2.95 million and I'm
like I'm that's the live plus seven I
don't know what that means is that key
demo or something you know look at this
results here we go adults across 25 to
54 The Late Show wins with a 0.5 with
614 000 viewers against Jimmy Kimmel's
live with 489 000 and the tonight's
shows with 477 000. okay that makes
sense so Colbert beats Kimmel and Fallon
with a 0.2 over their 0.1s I don't know
what that means and they don't give me
the I think that's like the share uh
the decimal is like no look at this look
at this across total viewers late night
averaged 1 million viewers over the
season so is that Colbert is he late
night no that was corden's that you just
I think you said later no look like oh
oh that's Myers and corden's Late Late
Show right this is so similar names of
such crap I know it's so stupid but it
does look like in the key demo it is
only like half a million viewers
yeah I mean I don't know anybody who
watches these shows yeah yeah I was
going to say but those are people our
age
yeah I mean also you get as many
Watchers as these like super highly
produced you know insane budget shows
yeah it's just I mean the margins are
incredible
we're putting we're doing crazy stuff
with it I can't say exactly what we're
doing but we're doing some
infrastructure stuff right now dancing
syringes yeah that's right dude that's
such a good bit yeah
dude
I I will hire 1 000 people to dress up
like syringes
let's go in DC yes oh my goodness that's
the thing like the Late Night show every
now and again there's some late night
stuff that that at least was decent in
the past so I thought Conan was pretty
funny but like I wasn't tuning in every
night it's a weird format because like
an incredibly good comedian can maybe
churn out an hour a year and you've got
you have these comedians you have to go
on stage every night and do like 45
minutes of material it's just even if
they're good and they're not ID logs
it's not going to be good yeah it's a
good point it used to be an interview
show we talked about this last week and
now the the interview format is on
YouTube people make their own they just
if they like you know Johnny Depp
doesn't need to wait to get invited on
The Tonight Show to talk to the crowd he
can just make it a YouTube video Yeah
and they're promoting stuff ways right
okay I'm promoting my movie and you're
like why am I watching you talk about
your movie I can just watch it's like
it's kind of like what people would
write reviews about video games I mean
people still trying to do that you just
go to YouTube and watch the gameplay
footage if I want to see if the movie's
good I just go to YouTube and watch the
clips I I just had a crazy idea I think
we should do it is to have bands
have bands yeah like these these shows
will periodically be like you know we
have a musical guest to play music or
whatever Friday nights maybe like we
used to do the Friday jams back in the
day we'll do a Friday night show and
then we'll also have a musical guest to
perform afterwards play music and we'll
just start taking over this space I
guess it's got to be like not not family
friendly that's a big problem with these
shows is they can't say the wrong thing
it's you can't give the middle finger to
the people during the show like
meanwhile you don't do it I know you see
but if we're gonna do like hard just
hardcore Rock scene bring it back full
on get [ __ ] getting people naked on
stage like I want a more jar yeah
um but just yeah I'm all about it let's
bring the real back to reality well look
I I can studio audience
I mean we could chickens chickens as the
audience
we've talked about doing Friday nights
at a venue and doing it like a live
thing uh I'll explain this to people who
don't know because I know a lot of
people probably do the reason we try not
to swear is not because we're worried
about YouTube or anything it's because
there are people who listen to this on
their way to work or picking up their
kids and I actually had we got people
emailing being like hey man I love your
show but like when you guys say these
things I don't want my kids to hear that
and I'm like that's fair point you know
if we don't have to swear we shouldn't
swear I guess we do it's about swearing
and profanity I find some things can be
profane without the cuss words like if
you can say things that are very graphic
sexually that aren't aren't cussing but
way worse for a kid to hear than saying
the f word and like totally agreed and
action movies with death and murder and
stuff I think with parents too they
don't even care so much about the word
it's the fact that now the kid just says
it all the time and they don't really
get it and then it's just like
inconvenience you know they just keep
they hear it and they go I just say this
all the time you're like you can't say
this at the grocery store no you can't
interesting yeah the f word has a lot of
different meanings depending on how you
use it very versatile words one of the
probably the most versatile I think so
yeah is it well adjective it's a verb
Let's uh we actually have a story to
talk about in in with kids and stuff we
have this from The New York Times it is
uh how a debut graphic Memoir became the
most banned book in the country crazy
Maya kobabi's book genderqueer about
coming out as a non-binary land of the
author at the center of a battle over
which books belong in schools and who
gets to make the decision so I don't
know if you could pull that up and we
can show the uh the image can we what
it's just yeah it's just the article
from New York Times okay yeah yeah so
the issue here is the New York Times
won't actually show you what's in the
book right because what actually got
this book banned from libraries is
sexually graphic images and the books
directed at minors
I
I can only describe it that way if I
were to actually say what the book
showed then parents would probably be
upset which I can respect but YouTube
absolutely would give us a flag a
million percent well so what will happen
is when the show's over
we'll go and it'll it'll give us the
yellow demonetization thing then we got
to request it if I describe to you the
images in the book because they're
sexually graphic we will get confirmed
demonetized and the clip from the show
will also be demonetized and you could
potentially YouTube will punish you with
with down ranking so these videos in the
past where they would apply codes to
your channel which would make it harder
for like Shadow Banning basically yeah
if I tell you what's in the book and
this book showing sexually graphic
images was being put in school libraries
and when people complain about it the
New York Times defends the book doesn't
show any of the images why could you
imagine what would happen to the New
York Times if they showed these these
graphic images it's it's it's people
doing things it is cart cartoon images
drawn of the author by the author
showing people engaging in activities
we'll call it it's young people though
isn't it yes one of it's yeah one of one
depicts miners oh my God one of the
images I think they both might depict
miners what what makes us the most
banned book like what is the
think about quantify that think about
what they're saying with this a book
with sexually graphic materials was in a
children's School library when got
removed it's the most banned book yeah
well Hustler is not allowed in the
school library yeah yeah Hustler is
definitely more of a Banned Book yeah
better articles too oh but Hustler was
never put in and then banned so
typically it works
no it was always banned yeah it's a
started out band it was never allowed so
so where where is the line and this is
why I think when it comes to left and
right there's it's just literally tribe
it's like do you bend the knee to what
the left is because if a kid walked into
a grade school with a hustler the
teachers would freak out if a kid walks
in with this book well it's educational
well it's not just the kid walking in
with it it's the teacher walking in with
it and showing it to the kids
right to jail yeah no I'm serious they
should be in prison yeah that should I
mean you are a danger to society and
you're a danger to children if you're
showing them pornographic images yes
that's it Hustler for instance is nudity
this is actual sex this book is showing
it's cartoon sex but it's sexuality
that's a little different thing and are
the people depicted are they actually
depicting minors and these cartoon
images in these drawings they're not
pretty sure the most notorious image
from this which depicts an adult
activity between two people is um
they're minors I'm pretty sure the point
if you can't tell yeah if you can't tell
you got to err on the side of yes
they're a minor it's called Lolly you
know you can't you can't mess with
cartoons of young looking but look at
this look at this this woman here
they're like they took the New York time
gets this woman to come out her name is
Mandy Zhang of Wappingers Fall New York
is planning to start a band Book Club
hey all right we can show up and bring
Playboy with us because that's not a lot
in schools either right this is the
fascinating thing to me because I hear
this argument from the left where
they're like they're trying to ban books
and I'm like there are tons of books
that are legitimately banned from these
schools when they talk about you know
wanting to ban critical race Theory
books just as a blanket statement I
can't remember who he had on the show
but I was like I don't want to do that I
think schools depending on the age
should critically discuss what this book
is my issue is when they inject the
ideology into their classes without
telling you what they're teaching you is
the Praxis of critical race Theory what
about having I don't want books man but
here's my point
it's not a Banned Book Club to bring
porn you're like these these books are
actually that's a great song that's like
an awesome book yeah
that's never considered joining the book
club that's a sketch or a cartoon so we
got two convenient to make content you
can you can either if you can take it
where people are like it's a Banned Book
Club and the book I bought is Playboy
but like they're literally no they're
making the argument for why the book
should be banned too yes what do you
mean they just don't realize it like can
you believe like they're making an
argument in favor of banning books
because when you when you use the phrase
book ban it doesn't really have a
positive connotation there's this book
band look what's on it you're like maybe
we should have a book ban maybe maybe
you shouldn't let children look at
everything in schools it's easy to make
your own book now too so any any psycho
can make a book about crazy stuff get it
in under the sensor radar like Amazon
you can publish your own stuff on Amazon
if you posted these pictures on
Instagram they would ban you yeah well
they would delete the post and give you
a warning yeah well and look at you had
Amazon insiders complaining about Matt
Walsh's book Johnny The Walrus being
number one and if I'm not mistaken they
were actually trying to de-rank that I
don't know about d-ranking okay they got
it removed from children's okay yeah so
they had it removed from the children's
section so that's not acceptable but
showing graphic glued images as far as
we understand which actually depict
miners is acceptable that is hideously
disgusting is there a way for people to
find this image so they know we're
talking about without actually having to
show it all over no yeah I mean if you
if you Google
know thine enemy you do need to know
what's in this book because the way the
New York Times is painting is this is
they took a picture that she didn't even
put in the book and they said oh this is
what the artist draws it's like oh Mom I
think I might be bi oh that's so sweet
how could Republicans possibly want to
ban this if this is actually what's in
the book that's crazy they're just being
mean but that is not what's in the book
and I was so relieved to see that this
tweet that the New York Times put out
about this article got freaking ratio
good right to heck because everyone's
like this is what's actually in the book
I was like did you guys put the picture
in the article of course they didn't can
you stop does this say 18 years enough
yes it does it does indeed it says right
there 18 years or not look at that where
where exactly is it uh reading age and
the little the the icons
uh no like the the all the row of art oh
here yeah there you go and it's not even
a it's not a kid's book they say
historical environmental biographical
fiction graphic novel so 18 years and up
so why would anyone complain that it's
not allowed in schools yeah although I
think they're perverts who want to groom
kids yeah it's literally it yeah or
they're ignorant and they're split
soldiers for a mass movement of
psychosis I've been over using that word
psychosis I know but I don't think it's
possible to dozen book and claim
ignorance doesn't New York Times dozens
of schools pulled it from library
shelves Republican officials in North
and South Carolina Texas Virginia called
for the books removal sometimes labeling
it pornographic okay suddenly Kebab is
at the center of a nationwide battle
over which books belong in schools yo
Amazon says 18 and up the Scandal is
that these were in schools in the first
place this is constantly to like a blue
state Red State debate where you know
blue States ago these are the books we
don't think are appropriate and you know
it'll be like Huckleberry Finn or
something yeah whatever you know like
they just they kind of go back and forth
and they just it's weird that they have
their it's usually race and sex but hold
on hold on look if the left this this is
the derangement and the Twisted nature
of the activists left
anyone any leftist could come out and
start speaking out against this and be
like this book shouldn't have been in
there we don't see it we see the
defensive we see the other times defense
of it they do come out and talk about
you know Huckleberry Finn oh it's got
old racist terminology it shouldn't be
in the schools it's racist and
insensitive there was a there was a big
story about a kid who complained because
they had to read the book and the book
uses the n-word and it's just like okay
that's a book which is contextual
history it was written for a period in
during a period and we could address
that critically and talk about it that's
fair this book is literally labeled
eight and up and depicts sex acts
between human between people and that
shouldn't be for children yeah and it's
just something some pervert made because
they want to show children and warp them
it's not as if this is something that's
part of America's foundational classical
literature that it would be important
for a kid to know what concerns me is
when someone is Warped as a child and
then grows up and warps children the
same way they were warped like this
cycle of abuse you know physical abuse a
kid's beat by their parents they grow up
and then they beat their kids I hate to
see the same thing happen with sexual
abuse so I'm not saying that
transgenderism is sexual abuse but I
would be afraid that some of it maybe no
no it's the exploitation when people are
abused their minds get pretty crazy so
when you have abusers masquerading as
the lgbtq positive whatever we've seen
this they they they they try and sneak
it under the radar they make they make
people look bad they make the whole
Community look bad but I think the left
is so instinctive to defend any and all
you end up with bad people getting away
with bad things because they'll just
feign being part of some Community I
want to mention Huckleberry Finn's in
the Library of Congress uh 1876
published Mark Twain I read like the
first third of the book I remember it
was awesome I honestly I'm trying to
think now too I'm like I honestly think
when I was in high school
Maybe not maybe elementary school but we
did read it and like you know you read
it out loud and I was like man if you
were that kid who got that page watch
out is that the one word damn where Huck
was going down the river on the raft
with Jim is that Hawking Jim on the
river yeah yeah that book's amazing yeah
I mean it's like yeah it's all the time
but yeah it's like if you especially now
PBS band Adventures of Huckleberry Finn
why is Huck Finn constant consistently
landed on the list of banned and
challenged books
because it talks about race and stuff
like that it uses the other word but I
mean absolutely but it's in a the gym is
like the black guy and they're good
friends Hawk like has massive respect
for the guy well isn't the per isn't the
point of the story that like he's
belittled for his race and it's
completely unfair yeah yeah he sees past
that like it's such a good book man it
was such a I didn't finish the book but
it was so good
but adult material that Amazon says is
for 18 and up just just can we just can
I my friends if ever someone comes to
you and they're like what are you
talking about and you know what's going
on and they don't believe you when you
tell them weird stuff's happening just
go to Amazon look up the book
genderqueer and say what age is the
recommendation and uh whoa this just
came out yeah
whoa this just broke right now what let
me just finish that point yeah finish
your point show them the genderqueer
thing show this is this is
groundbreaking but show them the
genderqueer thing show them the Banning
from schools and show them the outrage
and ladies and gentlemen do we have
makeup
Roe v Wade is gone yeah baby oh that is
beautiful that is a very good day for
this country there you go that is
incredible this is this I want to read
more I just saw the first tweet about it
oh my goodness Supreme Court has voted
to overturn Roe v Wade we hold that Roe
and Casey must be overruled Justice
Alita writes initial majority draft
circulated inside the court
oh my what this is nuts this is
incredible now you know now here's
here's the funny thing
whenever whenever issues of left and
right comes up they say when is Tim
going to defend abortion rights and I
just want to say one thing very clearly
when they come out and they're like the
left hasn't gone left and the right has
gone right
my entire life the Republicans wanted to
ban abortion outright
do you know what the Republicans
on a ban abortion still that hasn't
changed the left used to be in favor of
some restrictions like a compromise now
they want it completely unrestricted I'm
not going to defend you on that I want
restrictions
so so here's what here's where we are
what this is this is 8 32 PM breaking
the Supreme Court has voted to strike
down the landmark Roe v Wade decision
this is nuts according to initial draft
majority opinion written by Justice
Samuel Alito the draft opinion is a
full-footed unflinching repudiation of
the 1973 decision which guaranteed
federal constitutional protections of
abortion rights and a subsequent 1992
decision Planned Parenthood V Casey that
largely maintained that right wow we
hold that Rowan Casey must be overruled
he writes the document labeled as the
opinion of the Court it is time to heat
the Constitution and return the issue of
abortion to the people's elected
representatives
I just want to I just want to point out
like
during the show Lydia will like pull up
a story it's like something happening
but usually it's like oh we'll get to
that and then I saw this and I'm like
trying to make my point and I'm just
like distraction so what's he saying
that it becomes a state issue yes yeah
and this is because they strike down Roe
v Wade everything that every subsequent
uh court hearing that was based on Roe v
Wade has now struck as well yeah we're
saying it'll be what in two months okay
wow there's gonna be a lot of abortions
between now this is this is earlier than
we thought I thought it was going to
come out in June what's Planned
Parenthood versus Casey this is
incredible look that is off top of your
head
what are you asking me 1992 court cases
I'm not sure simply put using the
context clues it was a an additional
case in a similar vein that reaffirmed
the rights of abortion federally wow I
mean this is extremely good news I was
not expecting to be this happy at the
end of my day today well that's it I'm
moving to Canada
was egregiously wrong from the start its
reasoning was exceptionally weak and the
decision has had damaging consequences
and far from bringing about a national
settlement of the abortion issue Rowan
Casey of inflamed debate and deepened
division as I'll just say this
this is there there is no there there is
no middle ground in the issue of
abortion there's there's none there has
been attempts at compromise that's what
it used to be safe legal and rare that's
where my family was my I remember you
know my family my dad would say it's
always wrong
but you know sometimes there's issues
where we don't know if we have the right
and the government and stuff like that
so it's always a more libertarian
approach
what we're seeing now from the left is
the argument that it's constitutionally
enshrined to terminate the life of a
baby which goes well beyond any position
I've ever held but I've always been in
the more libertarian position which is a
very difficult position because there's
serious moral challenges to it that I
don't have the answers to so I don't
have a strong moral position other than
it is a crazy thing that it really like
splits right down the middle like I feel
like if you just took a random subset of
5 000 Americans it would be right like
50 50. but there's no it's be it's
because on the the on the on the merits
of the argument there is no middle
there's there's no rational compromise
on the legal it's not possible yeah
there's no there's no compromise and
it's also fascinating because when you
consider the fact that the Supreme Court
case on gay marriage was decided 10
years ago and basically the entire
population is in favor a very large
majority of the population is now and
you can lose your job basically for
saying you aren't then you consider the
fact that Roe v Wade was decided what 50
years ago and 73 yeah and so many people
have maintained their opposition to it
so the left never saw the cultural shift
that they wanted to with it uh thank God
for that this is a really incredible day
I mean there are millions and millions
of children who are not going to be
slaughtered because of this and so often
the right loses fails to take ground and
just allows the left to advance more
slowly
today we have experienced one of the
most incredible experiences that we
could as a movement because if we stand
for anything it has to be innocent life
I uh I remember when they they were I
remember them talking about when Roe was
passed there was a growing approval of
abortion among the states and when this
happened they were like approval changed
like people stopped approving of it and
I honestly hope that this is the first
in a long series of steps that we take
to send these issues back to the States
I am very hard line on abortion but this
has always been a state's issue it
should have always belonged to the
States because this is not something
that was given to the federal government
in the Constitution and the tenth
amendment is extremely explicit about
this anything that's not given to the
federal government should be left to the
States because the states are much more
in tune with what a smaller subset of
the population that live in that area
think and believe so hold on hold on
there a minute so I'm I'm trying to
tweet this out
but this is an initial draft of the
majority opinion it seems extremely
likely this is what's going to happen
but it was leaked right so it is still
early and the fear is because it was
leaked the left will Now launch some
kind of well that's why they leaked it
yeah until it's published like in the
next two months so it seems extremely
likely it will happen but what if the
left goes nuts what if they're going
what if yeah
sure my point is what if by then
they changed their vote oh well don't
don't they have a majority because I
think you went down and said that it was
all is it five to four and what happens
if antifa goes and burns down a bunch of
cities and then all of a sudden they're
like oh no we we changed our votes we
that was a that was a draft we we don't
agree do you think that would change
their minds or would that set them
harder I think I actually I don't know
if you guys do you guys hear that I
think it's the lady from the the women's
March
Roe v Wade growing up Roe v Wade was
like the gold standard from my my
liberal mother family it was always like
you know we got Roe v Wade we like
that's part of and that was only six
years before I was born but I guess that
was like such an intrinsic part of
women's rights this is according to my
parents generation I'm gonna say the two
magic words oh boy you guys ready for
the two magic words uh-oh does anybody
know what those magic words are gonna be
I don't know if you would Danny Sheamus
yeah
the the two words that Tim Poole likes
to bring up
touch of the sea second word w
can't win Chicago White Sox that's
pretty good Civil War
Stephen Marsh yeah I've got I've got to
figure out the musket yeah yeah I have a
civil war muscle no no no no no no
oh yeah keep your patterns I actually do
have a Civil War Union I'm a dumb
Canadian I don't know listen listen
ladies and gentlemen I don't know these
rules you need to hear this
Stephen Marsh wait on the show wrote a
book called the next Civil War I think
that's what it's called right I believe
so yeah he wrote he wrote a follow-up
article saying that he believed abortion
had the potential to be a similar moral
Catalyst now I I've been saying that as
well I want to read this for you this is
from Dan Diamond who is a Washington
Post reporter who said quote uh he's
quoting I think from an article he says
no draft decision in the modern history
of the court has been disclosed publicly
while a case was still pending this is
full on sabotage of our federal
government by a political faction we
cannot survive if after hearing this
news
if in two months they say due to
extenuating circumstances and extreme
political pressure we've changed our
position what do you think is going to
happen in this country well who leaked
it that's what I want to know so what is
this uh this opinion that Alito issues
is the only issue to the other justices
it sounds like they all voted for it I'm
totally having to move back to Canada so
one of these one of these they probably
did in a closed room I don't know the
process but one of these justices may or
may not have leaked this to one of their
aides and then that Aid leaked it to the
press or that Justice Just leaked it to
the Press either way this to me is
evidence that we need to get rid of all
of them and put new justices in Supreme
Court Justices if one of them is corrupt
that entire system is if they're if one
of those justices everything's correct I
mean yeah yeah I mean I mean then next
time we can't keep Justice opinions
secret anymore what about it the next
nine through a reality TV show very oh
this is this is crazy I'd watch it yeah
I mean everybody would walk in I
wouldn't be happy with that it's like
The Apprentice It's Trump oh my gosh and
you've got 35 candidates yeah and he's
like you're too far left get out you got
a rose quite frankly I I don't like I
don't like the decision you've made in
the past to be able to set a thing the
President should not be putting people
in the court like that that is insane
that's how it's been for 200 years
that's how it's worked I know but it's
just insane that no there's a
confirmation process yeah but it's like
a ground Court
and it's like the Senate gets to do it
it's not even that people don't even
have a say I wanna I wanna I wanna say a
few words my friend
so every winter
things calm down because people are
indoors and they can't go out and do
crazy things
and every winter for the past 11 years
or 10 years as I've been covering
conflict winter comes around and
everyone says I guess it's all over the
rides and the protesting and everything
is done and I'm like dude it's snowing
outside okay give it give it a few
months and in the summer you're gonna
see it get crazy again and then I was
thinking about this just uh recently
because Stephen Marsh wrote that article
that abortion could be it's he says
abortion is a similar moral issue to
what slavery was for the Civil War and
I've talked about that and then I was
like I wonder if a lot of people are
still thinking that there's not going to
be some escalation and then I'm just
like I genuinely believe something will
occur that will be an unprecedented
escalation we have never looks like this
a court that's what they're saying never
has a draft leak of a Supreme Court
decision been leaked in modern history
it is unprecedented
this is one of the most dramatic
escalations that there are Supreme Court
Justices sure as Ian mentions I don't
know if we get rid of all of them who
who have staff or someone leaked this to
the Press
just undercutting our entire system of
governance
I'm really worried about what's going to
happen over the next two months but hey
man don't be surprised if you see
rioting and smashing a window of
Destruction yeah
what's the status quo now but look look
I don't believe the left holds this as
to the same moral standard as the right
does to the right it's a very strong
moral to the left it's a tribal issue
that they talk about sometimes
but here's what I was thinking if the
ruling came out I didn't think that
there would be Mass rioting over this
the reason was the ruling is done what
they would do is they would start
petitioning and being like we've got to
win and we've got to get the courts
we've got to win the midterms
putting the the decision out two months
early is perfect
for the people who would who would Riot
now I genuinely believe we may see riots
because they want to influence what the
vote actually is now excuse my ignorance
about the but does the elections not
factor into this because the Supreme
Court they do they do not yeah I
wouldn't right so the Supreme Court said
unless you need someone to die or step
down in order to change that right so
this is the Supreme Court that currently
exists they're not elected they're
they're appointed and confirmed the
President says I want this person to be
a Supreme Court Justice then uh the
Senate then says yay or nay so typically
if the Senate is controlled by party a
but the president is a party B you're
not going to get it so you so you
usually need a presidency and a senate
of the same party or the at least same
politics to make something like this
happen
this is
this is going to get crazy
they should be voted in yeah it should
be a vote the people should vote on
Supreme Court Justices at this stage and
there should be 40 terms limits I
disagree because once you get that vote
in there you get the influence you get
the concern about possibly being
re-elected or whatever and if people
vote and make that decision they're like
oh we regret it we're going to recall
them I feel like there's so much more so
much more of a solid Factor when you
have the president put them into place
and then they don't have to worry about
a re-election and because it is a
lifetime appointment they don't shift so
much with the tide as regular politics
no no re-election you get four years and
you're out no real I don't want Justice
is concerned about running for office
ever no no no it's it's good that we
have at least one branch in my opinion
that is for life in Canada in Canada the
Senate yes Lydia just explained it yeah
but look how Canada is doing yeah not
great
you don't we putting people in charge of
the country for life is like a
dictatorship they have three branches
only one branch and they can impeach
them yeah so Congress can impeach a
Justice the President appoints Senate
confirms and we've got the elected
president we've got the elected elected
members of Congress they all have
varying degrees to their to their terms
Congress is two years Senate is six the
presidency is four that's a good thing
has that ever happened uh Court Justice
getting impeached uh is Thomas the
closest did they try no no they didn't
try to impeach him no no no they tried
to prevent him from being well they're
trying to prevent him from being
accusingly untoward Behavior but the
point is some people are appointed for
life and I think it's a good thing
because as Lydia pointed out they don't
they don't change the tides they stick
to their positions there there needs to
be an anchor Congress is very quick
every two years you get a who knows what
yeah although some people never leave
and then the Senate is six years which
is a bit longer in the presidency is for
these different amounts of times allow
there to be anchor positions so the
country doesn't just implode instantly
unfortunately it's not working so well
because the country looks like it's a
very slow implosion also it took the
Federal Reserve to come in and take over
the country and now abuse our system and
put these people in power for life and
then pay them off in the background yeah
there's been three impeachments of
justices the second one in 1804 yeah
they're like old like for drunkenness
and Insanity
you can't be a crazy drunk guy yeah
that's I think there should be a reason
why there needs to be one Supreme Court
Justice who is a drum are they supposed
to represent the nation all the time
he's he's the he's the tiebreaker and
he's drunk all the time lit up on moon
crazy and crazy yes well they'll be you
give us that triple X moonshine Sheamus
what do you think is going to happen I
don't know I can't make a prediction
here um I very much hope that this is
official that it is overturned I know it
appears as if this was leaked early I'm
not in the business of making
predictions in this day and age but
let's keep praying let me tell you you
know what the problem is with you
Sheamus yeah you conservative type
what's the problem with this you are
satisfied by the by restriction on
abortion going to the states I'm not
satisfied by it no I'm not at all no I
think we need to go further no yeah yeah
I would make it illegal Nationwide if
possible
out to international waters and do it no
then I mean you do you prosecute them
the same way you would to somebody took
a butt out to international waters to
kill their already born child yeah let
me reframe it I was trying to be I was
trying to be oh Sly
conservatives I'm bad at that that's the
conservative problem yeah conservatives
will very much be satisfied by saying
it's a state's rights issue whereas the
left outright's like bad like we want
unfettered access Nationwide no matter
what the left takes the extreme position
the right settles with the compromise
generally speaking Yeah that's usually
how the ride operates it's very sad I
think it is starting to change more
conservatives are waking up to the fact
that trying to meet in the middle is not
working for them y'all that's gonna get
crazy what's come about with the whole
Texas the the rule that they have
without the six weeks yeah like the
suing and didn't you know it's done what
has actually like happened uh other
states passed similarly yeah Louisiana
or something or Mississippi
let me I'll tell you what's going to
happen
right now I assure you there are tons of
red states that are immediately drafting
outright bans knowing that in two months
they've won
if doctors do it then they're gonna go
to prison a bunch of women do it are
they all going to go to prison
the doctors would go to prison yeah I
wanna I wanna I wanna ask you guys some
questions no yeah I've asked this
question I've asked this question um I
think only in the members only before
but I have a question if
you saw someone about to kill another
person you are legally allowed to
protect the life of others
so if an evil man was pinning down
another man choking him you could use
lethal Force against the aggressor to
save the life of the person being harmed
in in most circumstances obviously if
it's like there's a cop who's you know
attacking somebody because they're
fighting and you intervene you might get
trouble but if the cop was actually
trying to kill but like just strangle
the guy out maybe so here's the point
if Roe v Wade is overturned and in red
States they pass laws outright saying an
unborn child is a life
and a doctor is about to perform an
abortion
what would happen if someone intervened
to protect the life of that child as per
the law of their state this is where I
think we get into Civil War territory
yeah because now that we're it's getting
scary like the embalming of abortion
clinics coming back that's different
well but I'm saying people will be doing
it under that guys where they're saying
vigilante justice if there's no legal
distinction between saving the life of a
child and an unborn child because they
are legally the same thing and you have
a Doctor Who's like I am going to now
perform the the incision on the spine
and someone says I will stop you by any
means necessary you might end up with
stories where the courts say it was
self-defense to stop the killing of that
child
that's what so I think that's where we
can get into Civil War territory I'm
concerned about miscarriages man like a
six-month pregnant woman falls down and
hits her stomach and the baby dies and
then what are they going to charge her
with manslaughter because she didn't
protect and defend the baby's life she
allowed it into a dangerous situation I
guess in this sense it would be what the
actual procedure of right well then
you're going to see a bunch of women
falling over and landing on their
stomachs there are people yeah maybe I
mean they're just like they did but well
when abortion was illegal and they had
what all the back alley so they're
abortions I'm sure some women will find
a way I know that's true yeah so there
were back alley abortions all the
supposed numbers of women who died from
Back Alley abortions were literally
completely fabricated Bernard Nathanson
who founded nehrol admitted later on in
his life after he actually converted and
became pro-life because he saw the
errors of his ways that he was literally
just making all of it up
um but yeah that's the answer to that
question right now there are people who
will be driving their car no I'll tell
you a story from my neighborhood there
was an old man driving his car and he
ran over a 14 year old girl and when he
went he stopped put the car in reverse
and backed up not knowing what he hit
and crushed her head like a mountain he
did not get charged
uh why because in order to charge
someone you need several criteria and an
accident like this with an old guy they
said he wasn't negligent he was just an
old guy driving and he hit somebody
panicked and killed her he didn't see
the person before he hit it they they uh
he didn't see her he was driving
normally he was driving the speed limit
he was doing everything right but he was
just a bad driver and my understanding
is I don't think he got I'm pretty sure
he didn't get charged they just took his
license away from him there are a lot of
people who do things like you could be
driving down the you could be driving
and someone it could be pitch black on a
road and someone jumps in front of your
car and you hit them and you don't get
charged and they'll be like you were
driving you should have seen them then a
politician doesn't that happen to a
politician where he said he hit a deer
well I think he's getting charged yeah
well because he well he lied he was like
I think I hit a deer and he hit a person
and they're like we found goodness my
point is I really doubt that's brutal I
think in the circumstance where you're
driving your car and you hit somebody
and it was a real accident where the
person jumped out in front of you and it
wasn't you're you were doing everything
right you might still get charged if
it's a woman who has a miscarriage and
it goes to the hospital I think it may
happen but it'll be extremely rare that
the cops are going to be like let's lock
her up that's terrifying yeah I mean
there you'd have to find me an example
of that actually happening I know a
couple years ago there was a story where
a woman put like a fully developed
unborn child in a dumpster and so they I
think they were investigating to see
whether or not the child like was born
and then she put it in the dumpster or
if it was a miscarriage but I don't know
of any examples of any of the states
where abortion is currently restricted
or illegal where women are pursued for
having miscarriages in fact in the ones
that we've seen the penalty only falls
upon the doctor yeah you can't really
tell if it was an intentional
destruction of the fetus through
miscarriage or if the woman actually
miscarriage that's why it's scary to me
about charging people for that in a
place where abortion's illegal but you I
mean in abortion procedures after a
certain point they actually go in there
and they rip the child out
the spinal cord yeah they take a tool to
cut face of the neck and then start
dismembering it and yeah we've talked
about this yeah it's like I I think
what's going to happen now is these
there were a wave of red States they
were passing these like 16-week ban
11-week ban and that was the Catalyst
for getting to the Supreme Court and
then the Supreme Court said we're going
to go beyond your argument for your
16-week band you can do whatever you
want now I think red States will just be
like okay many of these same States I'm
willing to bet right now are drafting up
absolute bands like Oklahoma already did
one I wonder if they just have them
ready to go they do yeah like you know
break well there's there's two things
Wyoming there's some glass you know
exactly there's trigger laws yes that as
soon as it's let's say as soon as Roe v
Wade is overturned they instantly go
into effect but what I'm saying is right
now States seeing that Roe v Wade has
not been overturned yet but it will be
they're going to pass a law right now
and be like you can't sue us because
we're going to win in two months anyway
so good luck yeah I don't know hopefully
maybe you guys can explain to me why in
some states in some instances it is a
double homicide if a pregnant mother is
killed like in the case of lacy Peterson
and in other cases it's not does it just
depend on what the mother wants I would
argue that Roe v Wade should have made
that absolute Nationwide if you're going
to argue that abortion can be done in
any state in the country that with
without you know with only certain
limitations then you should not be able
to charge someone for killing a fetus
right because that would mean the
Supreme Court said you could kill
children right that is consistent yeah
right so getting rid of this now
now it makes sense that some states
might say it's a crime in some sites
might some states might say no right
it's possible that antifa loses their
mind over this but I will say that I
kind of hope that okay
yeah it seems likely it might happen it
might happen but I do hope that this
will be a red pill for these Supreme
Court Justices and then they can look at
this and say okay this is definitely
something that is should not be in the
control of the Supreme Court it should
be at the very least left to the
individual states and at possibly banned
out right because every single state has
prohibitions against murder obviously
and I think that this would be the
closest comparison we can make at this
point in time although it could also say
slavery but if every single state has
prohibitions against murder then you
should also be able to say that every
single stage should have similar
prohibitions against abortion we haven't
gone that far yet yeah exactly so one
argument that people will make when they
say abortion should be left up to the
states even though they believe it's
murder is that generally whether murder
or how to prosecute murder is left up to
individual states but that doesn't
really hold water because it's not as if
states are able able to say murder is
altogether legal here and we're not
going to go after anyone for committing
it I think the federal government would
step in at that point so I do believe
there's very good reasons I will
abortion at the federal level I think
every leftist nightmare is now about to
uh occur that's if you live in a city
like New York or Chicago or Los Angeles
nothing will change yeah literally
nothing because Roe v Wade just Returns
the right to the states and those States
already legalized well I will there will
be one thing changing in New York which
is I know so many like women who
honestly thought it was uh like
handmaid's tale like we're just like
we're living in the handmaid's tale and
they were saying it pretty
hyperbolically before and now it's gonna
be like for them to be like a little oh
my God in their minds a little less
they're gonna be like no it literally is
handmaid's tale everything is handmaid's
tale all the time it is I I know people
I've had conversations I know I had a
conversation with a girl at a comedy
club and she was crying this was before
kovid what even happened and she was
she's in tears being like no it's
literally like the handmaid's tale right
now and me and Ryan long were laughing
in her face like to the point where
she's like why are you laughing and
we're like we gotta go outside I'm sorry
and we have to excuse ourselves and now
so the conservative States behind the
glass they have these bills and then in
left-wing States they have the
handmaid's tail behind the glasses
that's gonna be a hot costume this year
in blue States
in blue States they have the the thing
that says break break the glass in case
of you know right-wing extremism and
it's already broken there's no glass
left the book's gone it took it out 20
years ago that's perfect that's perfect
there's no book left the woman runs he
goes where's the book
we've got to refill it we got to put
more books in yeah this feels like one
book also wait can I just make a point
so the only books they ever reference
are Harry Potter and handmaid's talents
like okay those are like television
shows slash movies so I know you didn't
read them yeah you do wait wait I got an
idea oh boy
the handmaid's Potter
oh we should write it the Harry hand me
hairy handmade and The Sorcerer's secret
oh yeah and uh it's a book about Harry
handmade and the Stone's tale boom are
the Wizards the bad guys in this one I
don't know they're like a religious sect
and they make all the women wear the
black robes and they force them to be
witches also it's funny because when you
look at the synopsis of a handmade style
it's like the men are able to have sex
with all the women they want and they're
what it's like is isn't this supposed to
be a Christian theocracy where it's all
about monogamy and one man one but like
this actually sounds more like the world
as it is now where really rich wealthy
dudes just sleep around with whoever
they want and then if she gets pregnant
they just kill the baby and his wife has
like the appearance kept up but he's
doing whatever he wants it's much more
in line with our because there's a lot
of that show I've never seen it the
whole I I know I've never seen it either
right yeah but from what I understand
from what's been explained to me it's
basically that uh there are women who
are forced to carry children for men who
basically own them isn't it like like
the population collapses something like
that
and then so the Christians like
Christian theocracy takes over and
they're like we need babies so the women
have to have babies and so they the
women are just forced to be you know
brood mares for the state that was a
George Carlin quote by the way
totalitarian the totalitarian Theocratic
government establ of Gideons establishes
a rule in the former United States or
I'm sorry of Gilead established
established his role in the United
States in the aftermath of a civil war
so I mean Tim you're always talking
about some more maybe you think it's a
handmaid's tale I kind of think it's a
handmade
look we got to admit it it is a
handmaid's tale tomorrow on Fox News
you're gonna see the the different
opinion commentators and journalists
together like it's time to tell who is
the handmade salad there's something
that isn't the Catholic churches the
point of it was like don't use birth
control because we want as many
Catholics born as possible and don't
have sex with people out of wedlock make
sure you stay in your Catholic Union
well it's it's make sure that you so
that's part of the natural law though I
mean that isn't specifically Catholic
basis yeah until like 50 years ago it
was every religion it was like wait till
you're married and don't use birth
control you know I don't know if you
know this but monogamy started back
um thousands of years ago because John
human argument didn't want his wife
messing around with other guys
it was originally humans would just you
know have orgies but uh vampirism began
to spread so to contain the spread of
the vampiric disease everybody had to to
pair up otherwise you know you'd be a
vampire I was just thinking about being
a vampire earlier today because I was
looking in the mirror of my white white
skin I haven't been outside in like
three days all that privilege James you
should do a cartoon where the the news
anchors are reporting and then the like
breaking news Roe v Wade and then the
women take off their clothes to have
handmaid's tale outfits underneath like
we told you this was coming so I did a
cartoon a while ago about the Supreme
Court not forcing nuns to pay for uh
Plan B pills and they're basically
surrounded by these feminists like my
life as a handmade style so I've done it
you guys should check it out you guys
should go watch that video right now but
uh I mean Margaret just bought a new
boat
she just read this she goes that just
bought me a new boat and handmaid's
towel has been renewed for like 30
Seasons she's on the phone right now
it's like of course I saw the news all
right she's gonna be imagine she's like
so evil she's like this is the greatest
thing that's ever happened she's like
she's like saw the news my publisher
leaked it she's she's like filling out a
donation form to a bunch of Republicans
that would be amazing she's like signing
the check and then the phone rings and
they're like don't send the check-in
she's like why it's done she goes ah she
tears
everything's according to plan right yes
so she's like the female uh what 1984
George Orwell oh my gosh that's true
she's like she's like the feminist
spoiled modern liberal woman George
Orwell yeah but she got in trouble
actually uh for some sort of gender
um mistake she made as well some sort of
thing she she kind of no like she's some
sort of you know she said the wrong
thing and then everybody who loved her
instantly kind of she said it instead of
they so like something very benign that
a 70 year old woman might make that
mistake and then she had people really
turning she's like my summer house just
got one story bigger isn't it hilarious
though that like that's something you
can kind of say about you either can say
about everyone and anyone or will be
able to say about him they got in
trouble for something they said about
gender I don't know like dude oh man so
my life is a handmaid's tale I'll tell
you that right riots are no rabbits I'm
you know I'm leaning towards riots just
because we haven't had riots by the way
like if you're a rioter yeah you're kind
of getting itchy right now you know
you've been like how long has it been
since the last round yeah you broke that
glass bro yeah in case of in case of
anything it's like a black man every
Target right now is calling up their
wood guy being like hey we need you to
come in board no no no that's true
though I'm willing to bet big chain
stores right now right now I'm willing
to bet Executives high up at big box
stores are sending out the alert they're
saying get notifications to every store
we want we want them ready to board up
at a moment's notice I mean I live right
beside Union Square in New York like I
guarantee you tomorrow or at least this
weekend there will be some huge thing
and you know there's there will be some
damage corporate is like all right
prepare the wood to board up the windows
and then PR prepare the letter of
solidarity to tell the rioters we're
standing with them as they burn our
building I mean in New York yeah in New
York they don't need uh like a logical
reason to write it of course but but the
New Yorkers that they don't damage too
much
I don't know about that Soho was like
destroyed really yeah you mean too much
relative to the amount of things there
are to damage yeah I guess yeah maybe
but like in Minneapolis they were
burning down buildings and police
stations and in New York there were no
burnings but there was there was a lot
of Steel I mean there was a there was a
few police officers that there's the cop
cars got Molotov cocktail oh that's
right yeah there were some what concerns
me is that if there's a riot in the in
the government really wants to go full
regime totalitarian they can send out
the feds martial law crack it down put
these people in prison for life totally
turn on them and then now we've got our
militocracy
Administration would do that I think
he's such a psycho like he's so
uncalculable and vapid that yeah I think
he's the kind of guy that could go
complete Insanity he just created a uh
what is this this this put this woman in
charge of his like disinformation regime
no that's not true the disinformation
yeah I don't know what to believe it's
the information government I don't trust
anyone guy to be in control in general
but I trust totally amen because this is
not we need more female Powers not the
handmade cell I don't wanna I don't want
to put that out there too much that it
could happen but it could happen it
could happen we're not we're like two
steps away from a totalitarian regime
military Crackdown you know what
actually really funny if like instead of
putting on hoodies and black bandanas
they all dress up like handmaids yeah
they're like rampaging through New York
with those red I'm telling you dude
you're joking about this is
seen this like ASAP like these these all
these antifa people decide to wear the
handmaid's tail outfit to make a point
but then night falls and they go nuts
and they're just running around in these
dresses and bonnets oh my goodness and
but you know what's funny too is like
the riots are going to be in Liberal
cities yeah yeah man before before the
last presidential election my area was
boarded up they're like we have Trump so
they're smashing up Democrat windows
and sticking their uh sticking a stick
in the spokes of their own bike you know
right right
let's destroy your own cities yeah good
job but that's actually a better meme
for the people who live in the city who
keep voting for these people they vote
for sympathizers for the writers and
then complain when their Windows get
smashed up but all right you shouldn't
vote for it in case you weren't alarmed
enough a vote for Democrats is a vote
for people to Riot in your city whenever
politics doesn't go the way they want
riots are dangerous and I'm kind of I do
advocate for bringing it no because I
wanna I gotta I gotta read this actually
the key paragraph that's being shared
right now of a handmaid's tale
deliberations on controversial cases in
the past have been fluid justices can
and sometimes do change their votes as
draft opinions circulate and major
decisions can be subject to multiple
drafts and vote trading sometimes until
just days before a decision is unveiled
the Court's holding will not be final
until it's published likely the next two
months yep so they are saying in this
article Riot now what they're saying is
several of the justices have expressed
that they're severely depressed and
don't know how they can go on in this
world right exactly Hillary Clinton said
yeah he recorded a report from a close
friend Hillary Clinton
hey oh man
yeah it's not gonna be good to be yeah
the family members of any of these uh
Supreme Court Justices not for the next
two months you're not going to be good
to be in anything so they got super
service details if you're a Supreme
Court Justice I thought that Trump
should have sent out the military to put
a put down the yeah yeah so that's
interesting
thing to say do you really think that
the Biden Administration would crack
down on antif
a when you talk about like the
disinformation
um act they're pushing through that is
100 pointed toward the right there's
nothing going against the left from the
bite Administration and there never will
be I don't well they're useful idiots
and they'll they'll be thrown under the
bus when it's time that's my concern oh
they legit leaked the actual entire PDF
oh yeah the whole thing dudes leaked wow
oh my it's wild
that's not cool yeah I gotta read this
who put the wrong person in the group
chat seriously 98 Pages oh wow wow do
you know who got leaked too political
yeah leaked they looked right to
Politico which is troubling to me
because this is the branch of government
that should not be political it
shouldn't be because like I was saying
earlier they're not elected they don't
need to worry about an upcoming midterm
or anything like that they just need to
focus on reading the Constitution and
trying to follow exactly as written and
this is the reason that they're kind of
protected from the vicissitudes of
Elections is so they don't have to be
influenced by politics and this to me
looks like they are trying to use antifa
against them which is deeply troubling
yeah I mean well that's because antifa
is the militant arm of the democratic
party yeah
I mean there are there are elected
officials and celebrity activists bail
those people out of jail whenever they
Riot and try to burn down a city to
intimidate the people in that City to
adopt their policy so it's pretty
straightforward at this point I think
they're having fun at the Met Gala right
now oh dude they're loving it they're
like it's all screams they're on the
ground rolling
and I was gonna make a statement I can't
believe I wore my white dress do you see
that that person wearing the weird like
metallic no the one you know what it's
probably 20. I know I bet you I bet you
every single person to take the
microphone on stage tonight is gonna say
something that they think is Really
Brave what is the point of that Met Gala
is well the Met of the Metropolitan
Museum of or whatever it's to raise
money for the museum I'm so sad it's
like a fundraiser but then they they
Rich they got you know Rich Elites and
then they got all like the Hollywood and
all that stuff into it made a whole
production out of it so this says right
now barricades are up around the Supreme
Court building just minutes after
reports I'm telling you my house my area
is gonna be on fire when I go tomorrow
yeah do you need a couch Danny I I I'm
going to
I'm going to tonight it's cold that you
live right outside of Union Square
New blocks from Union Square Danny nice
area we have a spare bedroom
I'll just honestly just put me in the
chicken coop just let me all live in
chicken soup
just just do a five dollar Super Chat to
release my breakfast yeah
50 dollars gets you a joke hey hey hey
chicken city is legit way nicer than New
York
right now it is no question yeah those
chickens have a sense of purpose I'm
really wondering like did I lock my door
yeah oh my gosh let me tell you it
wouldn't matter bro if antifa tried to
Riot in chicken City Roberto and Roberto
Jr
like the cops in New York back off and
then stand down but not Roberto Roberto
Jr yeah they'd be coming at you they'd
be drop kicking you an antifa would like
legitimately be scared of a chicken
running to I promise you yeah I promise
you they go on there but God Tim trains
hate crime chickens to attack me while
I'm fighting release chickens yeah this
really is kind of the perfect Stormville
because there's so much pent-up rage
from all the people who are ready to
riot after the election who didn't
because they won yeah
no no no
people probably just had like you know
cases of Molotov cocktails ready to go
Riot blue balls yeah no it really is
though they were ready to go there was
everything boarded up and then they go
ah like it was kind of a shot
it's like what do we do now it was going
to be the Super Bowl of riding it was
and they're wearing like hockey masks
and they're like let's go and they're
like Biden wins and they're like
but now
they're like finally and it's getting
warm perfect and and they'll get to ride
again in June we're supposed to are you
not supposed to smash riots to Oblivion
if they happen in your country you're
actually New York City smashed them as
they so it's difficult I've heard
different theories on this I've heard
some people say that part of the reason
it's so difficult to govern over
something like that is because you
really have to like nip it in the bud
early but when you do that it can appear
as if you're cracking down and people
are being peaceful but like as soon as
any violence starts you have to you have
to just immediately remove any violent
element because like fire it spreads
well but also the problem is is that
that's kind of how what they're saying
they're doing with like in Ottawa and
stuff they were trying to say that and
that was total like bull like yeah you
know especially the one right now with
the um the what is it the the bikers
right because they had they had the the
Convoy before and then now they have the
bikers and they just straight out came
out and they go oh you know we got to
make sure there's no like hate crimes
and you're like this is not on the table
like you're just kind of saying this to
plant the seed Brian Tyler Cohen says
when we expand the court this will be
why because you lost yeah yeah this
country is getting rid of the shreds
yeah they can't write rip the shreds
yeah to shred this is Antiquated It Was
Written Rogan says this from time to
time it was it was created in a time
when people rode on horseback and wrote
with quills and on paper and and they
had to go to Washington DC to partake in
the den now we're all right phone
calling and I disagree that's like
saying the circumference of the Earth
Earth was calculated at a time when
people were carving stone in tablets and
parchment I mean certainly we shouldn't
believe no yeah but we didn't have like
system was was created in a time when
men wore bath sheets and bathed in
public just demanding that they have to
be in Washington as a vulnerability and
also slows down the process I don't know
don't worry they don't show up a lot of
the time bro bro you got to read
political philosophy political science
the reason why we require our
politicians to travel around the country
to DC is that throughout history we our
the founding fathers knew the further
away leadership was from a capital the
more corruption would expand so you
needed some kind of oscillation to keep
the culture moving closer and then with
and then and then outside if you have a
capital
and that look at the Roman Empire the
further you got away from it the less
the laws mattered and everything started
falling apart but then you have video
chats so like distances warped time and
distance are kind of the same thing when
you can there's a reason why we don't
video chat people on this show because
these these Lefty guys on Twitter will
smack talk and scream and you'll say
come on the shelves have a real
conversation then when you go live
they'll bring some other random person
is or person in to go oh we Smackdown so
I don't play those games well if you're
under both as a government official then
you're not going to Swerve in something
no no the issue is you need to sit down
with people and have to confront them
and look them in the eyes if you're
debating yeah but if you're just making
a vote like they had on the Amber Heard
Johnny Depp trial they had a Witnesses
actually telecommune it in for the first
time they've ever seen it they don't
vote no they just came in and gave Texas
so so I think they should have to go in
and that's why they don't even have to
when Marjorie Taylor green goes in and
says I want a roll call vote and then
everyone's forced to come in that's why
I like what she's doing but they don't
that's the problem they do she got them
to that when the freedom caucus does
their Watch Remember is this they have
the freedom caucus because they're all
crooked the freedom caucus has to have
one person constantly there saying roll
call vote so it forces all the members
of Congress to do their jobs
but it's a good thing and if they didn't
have to be there they'd never go there
and they'd be like just sign me off on
yes on all of them and I'm gonna go
fundraise
they're running for reelection that's
another problem too the whole system's
busted up beyond beyond repair is that
safe to say well Thomas Jefferson had a
bold quote which I don't know if we
should say but it is a historical quote
about the tree of Liberty which everyone
probably understands intriguing there's
a general idea to get deleted from you
every every couple hundred years we need
to have like a reassessment of where
we're at with our laws and how they're
working the problem with that is if the
left is in Congress and we do a
reassessment they're going to be like we
will now strip the rights of half this
country away because we have half plus
one yep so it's like
how do you do it I think that the the
the the system the Constitutional
amendment process is is fairly good it's
allowed us to protect ourselves from uh
Democratic tyranny the tyranny of the
majority
there are there are there are crazy evil
people who will lie cheat and steal to
gain power and it's not hard for them to
Rally a bunch of dumb people to destroy
the Constitution but it's really hard to
do with the system we have if all they
had to do was rally 51
50.01 of people to take away your rights
your rights would be gone
they would find some way to do it so I
like the system we have but I certainly
think the amendment process is the means
by which we fix it and change it yeah
but it's also the way we can destroy it
like the 16th amendment created income
tax that's true that's true yeah so
you're saying the Constitution should
have never changed
well no I'm I don't think that's true I
like that you can amend the Constitution
but maybe these amendments should only
stand for a certain amount of time and
then they they wash off unless we
re-vote to have them put back on
oh but there wouldn't that potentially
uh have you lose the guns yeah there's a
problem oh I think I would imagine you
would exempt the Bill of Rights from
this
like so yeah I don't know those are
amendments let's read super chats
because we went along if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends if you haven't already go to
timcast.com become a member we are going
to have a members only show coming up at
11 p.m probably with a bunch of updates
on this it's going to get spicy for sure
and as a member you're helping support
our work with our crazy culture jamming
plans we're gonna do some fun stuff
um I don't I don't think I'm actually
going to hire a thousand people to dress
up like syringes and run around in DC
maybe that's a good idea actually it
might be funny they'd be like why are
all these people doing this I'm like oh
it was funny but we're going to do
things like that we're gonna do culture
jamming as marketing so let's rate some
super chats we got suomi uh perkiel
perkelly the quartering made a coffee
brand you should support them hmm I
don't know we were talking about
launching our coffee shop exclusively
selling regular coffee
I'm open to Jeremy's coffee though if
it's good let's uh send me a bag bro
all right let's see what's this what's
this
Louis Cordero says Tim I just got great
news I work for defense contract company
in LA and they just disbanded the mass
mask mandate also I really think you
should check out a band called havoc and
check out their lyrics on the album
conformicide
interesting
rylo says Jeremy from the quartering
launched a coffee company called coffee
brand coffee check it out if you like
his content I am not associated with
Jeremy ooh competition huh
all right
let's see is Jeremy just sending people
over here apparently
a lot of people are mentioning this
another question yeah I saw several of
them he's got coffee those three great
coffee all all right good marketing
all right all right no more coffee no
more coffee
Eric Miller says check out Liberty doll
on YouTube she covered a story about how
NBC and Pennsylvania ag office broke
federal law for a story about gun
control interesting
I would also like to shout out craigler
Coffey Adam crigler's coffee brand which
is also stupendously good the gamer uh
blend particularly I remember
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
we need not forget that before Twitter
twitterish Elon was the SpaceX guy Tesla
guy the boring Co guy the left can
radicalize anyone against them that's
right
no dude he's an idiot he's not bright
yeah he's not a very bright guy he
accidentally made PayPal yeah no look
look like if I was born okay sorry about
that right he fell down and he dropped
PayPal on the ground
and his credit card fell into the floppy
disk drive and he went and it worked it
worked yeah yeah you just had all it
only works if you have a bunch of money
on the right place right time yeah dude
if I was born in the same circumstances
as like Elon Musk in his background I
would have like five times as much money
as him oh yeah he would have been like
five paypals he sold them all to each
other yeah that's right if my dad gave
me a small loan of a million dollars I'd
have two billion dollars
Trump has like three
all right Donald it's six okay six
billion I used to have more Donovan
Davis has Tim the left are literally the
Sith they misuse and abuse the tools and
people around them for their selfish
Psychopathic ends the Sith can't hold on
hold on to power but can only attain it
due to their arrogance and craving of
power for the sake of power does that
mean that the right are the Jedi
well you know the left took the word
Jedi right Justice Equity diversity and
inclusion watch sounds like a sick and
now they have Jedi classes what yep so
these kids go there thinking they're
gonna get to learn to use the force and
instead they're having beliefs forced on
them oh
laughs
all right let's see
Ola says Tim what dates were you in
Ukraine comments on as of I dance for
Boda right sector Stephen Bandera et
cetera comment Union house in Odessa as
well
I was in um it's all on it's on Vice if
you just look up you know the euromide
and stuff I think we were there maybe
like around the new year
I think it was like maybe November of
2013 or something like that
Bandera is interesting the step on
Bandera I think is his name he was like
I don't know if he's considered him a
Nazi but he considered himself a Nazi he
was and he was just like the hardcore
nationalist violent movement during
World War II was it yeah for sure okay
yeah yeah all right Joseph says you are
correct Tim I live in rural Minnesota
and even Republican Boomers believe this
stuff around here that's right this is
what's so bizarre about it right because
these news networks cater to a more
left-wing audience when you're looking
at CNN and MSNBC and the boomers are the
only people who watch it but they were
the ones who prided themselves on being
the non-conformist generation that stood
up to Authority they're like I'm only
gonna get my news from the authorities
yeah I mean there's Boomers on both
sides I mean there are boomers on both
sides but the Boomers on the right are
actually like look at this link I got
from
conspiracy.blogspot.net that proves that
and then they click it it's like a
phishing scan wait where's my money go
it's it's americanpatriate Warriors
like look this proves it it's like
Trump's gonna be president in a week
look at this son that website is real is
it yes oh my goodness dot website Brian
let's see was it say Schnur demand
results Tim Elon pays attention and will
format subliminal results where it's due
let's grab the narrative be relevant the
zombies need a shake that's why we are
planning a bunch you know I wish we
could do everything at once all this
crazy culture jamming stuff but you
can't you've got to do one thing wait a
month do one thing wait a month do one
thing because if you did like 10 things
in one month it just wouldn't be
effective at all you'd be like just
throwing everything at the wall and it
wouldn't work so we've got some plans
y'all liked the new the New York I'm
sorry the Times Square thing we did
we've got some plans
um
akin to like hiring a thousand people
dress up like syringes and run around a
city huh yeah you know something like
that but not quite like that we've got
plans look look there's there's a lot of
syringes out in La already
yeah well that's true we just syringes
up as people Yeah well yeah hey Elon I
want to advise you just to kind of lay
off the going after people thing and
keep creating stuff
it's amazing he has time for both huh I
don't know when he came out and started
ragging on the media about Epstein I'm
kind of I'm kind of happy it's
entertaining but I just I like the stuff
you're building he's waking people up
they're probably tons of people who are
like what's that about yeah no I just
don't want another pariah
well since 2018 he's been talking about
something that he called American
pravino which is where he was wanting to
hold the media accountable on his own
site so I think it's just him continuing
that idea
Morgan H says hey Tim looks like Vice is
trying to find a buyer you should make
an offer 10 bucks 10 bucks 10 bucks too
much bit High yes dude I hope it was
virtue.com you know are they really
trying to sell because like dude if they
sold I don't know nine years ago you
bought Vice
seriously talk about buying high and
selling low like advice is are they
really talking about selling they're
guessing maybe then games Disney wrote
down their investment to zero dollars
we're like half a billion I mean it's
probably one of those things where you
buy them you go yeah you have 400
million dollars worth of debt now enjoy
yeah oh yeah yeah it's like they pay you
to take it yeah they did they did take
on a bunch of debt recently so there's
uh several ways you can you can get
investment so I think they took debt
which is like a loan basically
so they owe money tpg capital is their
biggest owner 44 really Disney and a e
networks are on the other 2020
thereabouts and then a guy Soros owns 10
Source fund management does he really
support such a prankster that guy it's
just the brave search
and then Shane Smith oh it has 20 Zach
snow says just because Tim said Here
Comes Here Come the ones Ian here's a 20
spin the UFO that is what I'm talking
about did you see Ian I bought the air
things
so I bought the air thing it's
downstairs okay next time I'll bring the
air thing it's the air thing wobbly
wobbly cleaner wobbly spin wobbly
spinning
strange quarks as Tim you should get
flags for the Blimp Ministry of Truth
and fly it somewhere cool 59 year old
Boomer member here that appreciates you
all yeah so we have the let's go let's
go uh Brandon blimp we could we could do
something with the blimp you see what
you see our blimp no I haven't seen this
huge blimp what is it like 20 feet long
yeah yeah I think it is
we put let's go Brandon on the sides and
flew it around uh here well we flew it
around out here we just made it because
I wanted to
um retroactively make Wikipedia wrong
right I'm sorry right right because they
they once wrote that I invented a
Zeppelin and then it wasn't true and
they wouldn't get rid of it and then
eventually after a few years they did so
I decided to actually make the Zeppelin
so they'd be forced to put it back in
and now I did it but they're still not
putting it back in which is just not
fair but does that count as inventing is
up yes no so it was a it was a live
streaming Zeppelin modification wow so
they're like Tim Poole invented as apple
and that could do live streaming from
the internet and so we we hired a guy
and we built one it's a weird thing for
someone to make up about you like that
doesn't even sound like a hater would
say because we had done I had done I had
done some of the first work in drone
journalism I actually went down with
like the the American drone coalition
government program like where can we set
up drone research and they had no idea
what they were doing back in the day
when when drone commercial drones
started getting released like I'm
talking to these guys on Skype from the
government yeah and when I was like
think about what someone could put on a
drone and they're like like what and I'm
like like something dangerous like what
like a chemical and they're like and and
then they fly it into New York and
they're like oh they're like sir are you
planning to fly chemicals into New York
they arrest you no I was like you guys
need ways to disable these things within
certain perimeters like they just stop
because people like this cheap
technology but um we ended up doing a
bunch of crazy
hypotheses and theoretical stuff one of
the ideas was making a zeppelin but it
was literally literally like me talking
to a journalist and being like we have a
drone the Drone can live broadcast over
the Internet we built that we hacked it
me and my friends and I was like what we
want to do is a whole bunch of crazy
stuff we want to be able to send it
through mobile next we want to get like
a zeppelin that could do something
similar and they're like yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then they wrote Temple invented
a Zeppelin and like I never said that I
was just spitballing ideas
just all it was all right let's read
some more
Colonel Cornelius Cornwall says chicken
city is awesome but no posting links do
we have permission to run a
non-affiliated Discord for posting links
send an email to spin the UFO I don't
know um we have a Wikipedia we have a
Wiki a chicken City Wiki unlike Wikia
fandom or something
so yeah so people can make articles for
like Sarah and Roberto and Margaret they
were partying this morning did you hear
that yeah probably 6 a.m I don't know
what the party was all about but right
when they woke up they were just funny
at it I go out there periodically and
scold the chickens for not working hard
enough and only partying and then it's
just funny because it's like you
chickens better not be partying out here
you better get back to work and then and
then when the chicken party happens I'm
like oh you chickens well that's the
thrill of it the audience doesn't
actually know that you're in on it
that's right oh I know yeah so we're
we're planning the commercial for Tucker
and it's going to be
um did we do we do we say what the
trailer is going to be already we did it
right uh I don't know do not know I
think we said on the members only it's
going to be that an old man Withers be
is trying to plow out chicken City to
put up a parking lot for his shopping
center and then he's complaining to the
city about all the parties and then the
city inspector is like if these parties
keep continuing in these complaints
we're gonna have to shut you down and
then we're like you mean if people give
five dollars they can help us raise
money by feeding the chickens to save
chicken City and it's gonna be and then
and then at the end it's like the old
man and he's like these chickens have
won ah what the heck and then he throws
his Cane starts dancing with the
chickens and then media matter says Tim
Poole launched a false advertisement
campaign fooling people into donating to
his Pro chick and charity when it went
right into his own pocket it's not a
charity it's a four business a
for-profit Enterprise you're saying but
you're telling the public that this is
their chance to save chicken City this
is fraudulent
well it's a movie trailer though so we
we'd be doing a commercial for uh okay
that's how you get away with your lies
all right it's a movie trailer just like
Jon Stewart clown nose on clown nose off
yeah you need a disclaimer at the
beginning yeah the following movie
doesn't
existing sexually based offenses are
considered especially
for you all right all right
Let's uh let's grab a Super Chat
Abba what does it say a basic bro there
you go Tim what do you do to unwind
Danny do your best impression of Ryan
all right I'm not an impression guy I
don't do Impressions you do it I don't
even know if I can do Ryan I don't think
I can do a ride in person it would be
smart just like he's just kind of like
he's gonna like raspy but that's not
doesn't sound like I can do like that's
what yeah my yeah it's not really an
impressive shots like this
one it kind of comes down when he talks
a little bit yeah he's always like this
a little bit Yeah but it's like it's
hard it's a very unique sound I'm not
perfect so uh to unwind I don't know if
I do unwind
so here's how my day goes I I woke up
today at 6 30 A.M and then you know just
morning routine stuff you you know pluck
your nose hairs and yeah your face what
and then I started reading the news I
started I read it as soon as I wake up
today I woke up at 6 30 because I wake
up with the sun what's your news where
do you go Twitter right away yeah
Twitter so my Twitter is a lot of the
major news outlets and then other you
know political individuals so then
around like I don't know 7 30 I'm
drinking coffee and I'm reading the news
I record my first segment at nine then I
read more news and stuff like that talk
with The Newsroom we're dealing with
paperwork and stuff and building stuff
business stuff then I record again at
noon then I record again at um I think
recorded at two then I skated for about
an hour and a half or so I posted that
on Instagram then I made a keto grilled
cheese yes it was uh almond and walnut
flour with egg and then you you know
microwave it and then and then we did we
came to do the show nice so uh and then
on the weekends I just sit there staring
at the wall frustrated shaking like I
need to make more videos no that's not
true it's a much more Blank Stare than
that I don't want to do a show on the
weekend do you I use
like this last weekend I was like man I
want to create something what go do
stuff no the issue was that I mean
for I think for three years zero days
off working every single day of the week
and the problem was I didn't have time
for any other business development
couldn't go to the bank couldn't do
paperwork couldn't plan stuff and I was
like you gotta I gotta take weekends off
man
um and now weekends are just kind of
boring but I guess you know just skate
the whole like weekend weekday thing is
kind of antiquated too like what's the
difference every day there's no news on
Saturday so Saturdays are extremely
difficult to produce for because nobody
works but that's that's what confuses me
why does no one work why have we decided
as a society that Monday through Friday
we work Saturday and Sunday we don't and
we'll change the way we describe the
days you could do Wednesday to Sunday
and then Monday and Tuesday just become
well it's because Saturday and Sunday
are both the Sabbath so it's a religious
literally they're both yeah depending on
which which religion and you're supposed
to rest
you are supposed to is that it right the
rest of the Lord's Day in the Sabbath
yeah so yes basically basically but also
I think there's there's also just value
in general about having
time off for people you know yeah yeah
clear the mind yeah we got a good one
here this is Adam gray says senate
election needs to go back to the state
legislature appointment that is a check
and balance on the Supreme Court we lost
when it was made to be popular vote
agreed what is that the 17th
you want to look up 17th Amendment yeah
let me look it up let me look it up let
me look let's look at this I think it's
the 17th Amendment and I want to make
sure real quick
you have it yeah popular election of
senators abolish it no no feel it one of
the weirdest things about America is
that you guys vote for judges here yeah
that's so strange to me well what do you
Canadians do they're like truckers in
jail I don't want to hear it
I mean I love America but like they're
not always lawyers right like judges
yeah like judges here they can just you
just kind of 99 they're lawyers okay but
they're not always sometimes they're not
and you're like what was that about yeah
yeah like in Canada at least they're
always lawyers I don't know man I don't
trust a lawyer to decide a case I mean
that seems but in a judge sense I mean I
guess Jerry Springer is he a lawyer
that's a good question I don't know let
me listen Eric Nielsen says
homeschooling is possible Waldorf
Essentials and season of seven virtual
school is empowering parents take charge
of their kids education very cool
nay Slayer says Louisiana has a trigger
law making abortion illegal immediately
upon Roe being overturned amazing and I
said it but I'll say it again right now
there are probably States being like we
can enact a total outright ban because
we know we're going to win in two months
so just do it well there's probably a
bunch of them tomorrow morning yep
they might they're probably like we have
trigger laws but uh let's just do it now
they'll get sued and that's it it's over
but I imagine what will happen is
there's going to be more lawsuits and
more challenges and different ways that
will end up going to the Supreme Court
and if the court changes by one vote
there you go
one vote
all right true business says and
decentralization begins
oh man
okay
what is this one can I read this one
Ricky says make abortion legal but
anytime a woman gets pregnant an
attorney will be appointed to the fetus
someone needs to stand for those who
can't stand that would be interesting
because that would just prevent all
abortions yeah I mean how can you give
the death penalty to someone who hasn't
done anything I just want to see that
lawyer goes your honor my client just
threw up inside the womb yeah
oh no I guess what sir your honor my
client doesn't want to die yeah okay
I guess they're not alive at that point
you have to sue the fetus inside you
yeah
I'm suing you to get on my body
oh I'm gonna sneeze all right let's go
Bernie cats are what smacky frog that
killed me which one smacky frog you are
a handmaid
I said you're a handmaid Harry
amazing fantastic yeah can we get
someone to write that yeah I'll I'll
text it to you what is it Harry
I don't like that very handmade it's
different sounds tale or something like
that
you're a handmade Harry
it's a woman named Harry or what oh my
gosh all right all right name is of
Harry
was I gonna read Bernie katzroy says Tim
along with classic American literature
like Mark Twain's works I will always be
said and that the same was done to the
Laura Ingalls Wilder award those little
House books many of us grew up on
interesting I'm not familiar
Nash McGraw says compromise the right
gives up the death penalty the left
gives up abortion pro-life across the
board hey how about that
no killing everyone's vegan no
that then why do you have
slave prisoners in that chicken coop who
you force to make money for you you
force them into labor and profit this
already Sheamus there is a pandemic
right now and I am keeping them safe in
that pen from the pandemic that they're
not allowed to leave from I didn't see
one chicken in a mask oh wow try again
well you know
they don't have to wear a mask but there
really is a chicken pandemic going on I
know that's kind of keep excited about
this so in exchange for that safety you
know they just got to do as they're told
yeah yeah yeah it's killing all the
chickens so um you know these chickens
just it's it's you know 15 days as well
the spread started January of 2021
and uh just got to keep going until the
cases go down but they've only gotten
worse so how would I'm curious how that
would be transmitted to the chickens
that you have like a chicken from
another another chicken City runs on
over and he coughs on one of your
chickens well we bought chickens or they
go eating before 8 PM
um without their masks like what how
would a chicken what happens is if you
get the chickens wet after midnight it's
true then that's what does it yeah don't
feed them no matter how much they ask
you no I'm curious I'm actually
genuinely curious about that how does
that how could that spread to your
eating if they come in contact with
other chickens or you can poop or
anything like that jet stream
or you're probably pretty safe yeah but
uh we bought chickens so they had to be
quarantined oh I get what you're saying
yeah all right Baron of gray matter says
the leaking of this decision could be
construed as an Insurrection because it
incites violence against the government
these are dangerous times
I don't think so but I see what you're
saying you're a handmade Harry now get
to work
yo I can't believe that's crazy people
reporting on this just Roe v Wade wow
Raymond g Stanley Jr says wow Sheamus
yes maybe a bit louder sir sorry I was
very happy when I was yelling about
someone had a funny one but it just
disappeared did you say bro v Wade early
bro
v wait oh my there's a joke in there so
there is a joke out there it's about
like all the bro choicers like I care
about women's rights and it's like
literally just like one and consequence
for your sexual access all right waffle
Sensei says the left argues the 14th
Amendment prevents the government from
intervening in a woman's personal life
and choices life liberty Pursuit of
Happiness and the baby is property the
right says the baby has human rights so
the left pretends babies aren't human
agreed that's the problem with the whole
argument with the left is that you know
like I think it was vosh we had here
because we rarely have left us and he
said when he was asked I think Charlie
Kirk asked him when is it when is a baby
like alive he said I don't know sometime
after birth and it's just like come on
like there are babies that can be born
21 weeks yeah that could survive I asked
this question of wash on Twitter it's
funny how like so many of these lefties
just lose their minds and they're a
waste of time to interact with but with
vosh I asked him if there was a
procedure where a baby at any stage a
fetus could be taken out and implanted
in a faux womb do you think that should
be mandated for all all you know
pregnancy terminations or do you think
it doesn't matter
and then he said I think his answer was
something was like it would have to be
up to the mother to decide or something
like that it would be her choice and
then I asked him if a woman is punched
in the stomach by a man and she's
pregnant but miscarries because of it
should there be enhanced penalties
because of the baby's death or
uh and if there are should the charges
be as the baby the baby is the victim or
the or the mother is the victim or
should there be no additional charges at
all
and then he responded with the law has
to be consistent and there would be
additional charges or whatever which
didn't really answer the question but my
point was if
you want additional charges for punching
a pregnant woman
what are those charges stemming from the
rights of the baby like the baby was
attacked and harmed or the rights of the
woman because the pregnancy is something
special to her that you took away from
her as property I think it's the rights
of the woman personally then the right
to the woman then it wouldn't matter
that she miscarried of course not unless
you consider the baby to be her property
in that case her property was damaged
you know what gets me is like it I have
no responsibility to keep you alive
Sheamus like that's your job and my job
is to keep myself alive so why is it
these little babies are born and people
feel like they have a Duty or a right to
keep like they have a to keep it alive
if no one wants it alive yeah also
because you're not my parent but a
parent does have a responsibility to
care for their child if there is no
parent or if the parent doesn't want it
for whatever I guess if that doesn't
want it as kind of we're gonna say uh if
a parent has a child they don't want and
they say just keep the kid out of the
house they go to prison yeah yeah you'd
have to give it up for adoption yeah but
but you can literally take a baby and
put on the doorstep of a police station
and walk away fire department yeah fire
departments you can't take someone
else's baby and put them on the doorstep
of the police station hold on so
everybody knows give birth and then put
the baby on a fire department this is
the crazy thing when you hear these
stories about you know prom night
dumpster babies the the woman like in
many instances have has given birth and
then just throws the baby in a dumpster
and it's like dude you can walk to a
fire department and just knock and put
the baby there and it's legal you're
allowed as long as someone sees it no no
you're just like you put the baby there
then what responsibility does the fire
department have of keeping that thing
alive no it's not a bunch of
firefighters raising the baby
what kind of sitcom do you think this is
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we got
[Laughter]
but then it gets heartwarming where it's
like he's the big kid's like seven and
they're reading the book they're like
how to be a fireman they're reading like
the instructions
he's like he becomes a little psycho he
plays with mass matches
fire all the time it has to end with
like that's the one where they gotta
deal with it yeah the end of the movie
is an epilogue where it's like 20 years
later and the kid's just like 6'3 super
ripped and like a heroic firefighter no
I was gonna say it's like this is a
story about how saving a life is
important well this actually sounds more
like a story about a superhero
firefighter and then we hear his
backstory and his backstory is that it's
awesome oh yeah it would be like it'll
start with him explaining like how did
you come to be yeah he's narrow he's the
narrator he's like well I'll start a
reveal on Prom Night
repeal
yeah the woman had no other choice
all right we have a lot of funny super
chats but we'll just read out we'll read
one more because we're going along we
gotta get this Members Only
all right Carlos Toro says Tim how could
those Supreme Court votes been so
straight As far as we remember one of
them couldn't Define what a woman was
she might be voting on men's abortion
since they menstruate as well it'd be
funny if katanji voted in favor and like
Roberts voted to uh he voted for Roe v
Wade and she voted against it because
she was confused and didn't know what a
woman was so it was like it was supposed
to be made upheld but she didn't know
what a woman was so she was like men's
rights you know I was told by a number
of left-wingers that if men could get
pregnant we wouldn't even be debating
abortion uh man can get pregnant
again with the times come on all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with all of your
friends tell them guys this is the best
show you should watch it because that
really helps we have spent zero dollars
marketing this show the final Super Chat
wait where do you guys think
firefighters come from
we only have firefighters because women
give up their babies that's why we do it
that's what we do what is that name by
the way I don't to steal their joke
without giving their names it's just a
bunch of random letters all right smash
the like button head over to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have that
members only show coming up at 11 PM but
if you want to support us doing our
Strange culture Jammy plans wait till
you see what we got in store if you like
the Times Square billboard we got more
coming and boy are we gonna are we gonna
get some people all rustled up so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
like I said you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
Danny uh at Danny jokes everywhere
tomorrow night on my YouTube youtube.com
dannypaulstock it's 9pm low value mail
it's a call-in show anybody who's
watching can call in it's a fun time and
then Friday uh the boys cast with Ryan
long new episode
I am Seamus goglin I got a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we upload a
new cartoon every single week I just got
a bunch of ideas
so please do the firefighter subscribe
hit the notification Bell when people go
to low value mail where is it uh they
can just if they type in low value mail
m-a-i-l or it's just on my YouTube
youtube.com my name Danny and then the
call-in is that all there like all the
images yeah 9pm you'll see it it's uh
you can just call once the phone Line's
open you can call in uh it's I bill it
as like a bad advice show but we can
talk about whatever it's it's fun I give
really bad advice I give some good
advice sometimes and uh but it's just a
fun time I want to give a special shout
out to everyone out in chat that was
rolling 20s for me all night I saw tons
of 20s in the chat tonight and I'm
looking for 20 more of them tomorrow so
I love you all and I'll see you later so
Tim said that we haven't done any
marketing I don't think that's entirely
true because all evening I've been
getting I don't know if you guys are
familiar with iFunny I'm sure some of
you guys are on there it tends to be
conservative but they have a lot of
memes and a lot of our titles from our
Clips are going viral on iFunny so he's
just sending me these screenshots I'm
like that's not paid marketing weird
it's not paid marketing it's correct but
it is a form of marketing which I love
the viral marketing not paid we've not
spent any money on marketing for this
show right it's all done that will
change it's all Grassroots which I
really love I think that's even cooler
than I remember the like several people
being like so you know to get to this
point like how much did you have to
spend in marketing and I was like
nothing and they were like wait what
I was like we didn't spend any money and
they're like you mean that your
Channel's organic yeah all of it and I
was like yeah it's all organic and they
were like whoa that's kind of thing
about one of the things about YouTube
that really is great is that it's
marketing is built into the system
itself so like it will propagate you to
the Top If your stuff is good as well no
bro not all the time most most shows are
marketing yeah yeah even even PewDiePie
would complain about the YouTube
algorithm and the algorithm is really
about this question anyway you guys can
follow me at sour patchesonminds.com and
uh Twitter and I will see you all later
we will see you all over at timcast.com
and while you're waiting head over to
chicken City and watch some sleeping
chickens just go to chickencitylive.com
and you'll see that live stream right
there and they're all just peacefully
slumbering and then at 11 PM we'll
publish that members only and we'll see
y'all there bye guys